what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the
pregame before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos guys
like the video on your way in also guys
get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt today look if you look at
society and just say we're in a decline
just know we wouldn't be in a decline
right now if women didn't get the right
to vote in n 1920 you know every you
know the anti-suffrage Jets you know
what they said they said if women vote
and these were wives and mothers that
said this they said if women get the
right to vote the family unit will be
destroyed and they'll spend too much
money look where we're at hundred years
later take that [__] away okay guys a
couple announcements so the first thing
is um we are going to be taking
questions and comments through super
chats please don't Super Chat anything
that makes it really awkward to have a
conversation okay please be semi nicer
right um over how many dollars um are we
going to take today 20 okay over $20
Super chats we will read and how many
likes to open up the chat to non-members
a thousand okay a th likes and we will
open up the chat to non-members
otherwise get yourself a membership tier
from the $5 tier $10 tier is Discord
behind the scenes Vlogs third tier um is
connect with me on social media and
fourth tier is a one-on-one call with me
once a month want to know how to get a
million subscribers in a year um sign up
for the fourth tier also guys we are
signing talents here in our London um in
our London office so if you think you
have what it takes to be a YouTuber
pitch me your show on Instagram it's
helpful if I see videos of you talking
and what your specific idea is for a
show please stop pitching me the same
show that I already do um that's not
like it's got to be something different
all right guys um okay um I think that's
all of my announcements we did the
Meetup guys but if you want to be
notified of our next Meetup in London
sign up for our Google forms list that
should be in the description that way
you're notified okay guys um welcome to
the show thank you all for coming why
don't we go around say your name your
age your relationship status and a fun
fact about yourself starting here go
around and then second row okay Laura
from London um 30s and uh single 30s 30
what yeah cuz every time I say it you
look at me funny is it 30 is it 35 yeah
okay I think I think I remember
I don't know why the women say it
proudly it's all right because every
time you look at me like
this oh I don't look at you you know I I
think you I actually was surprised the
first time you look young that was why I
looked at you like that go ahead hi I'm
ran I'm from London and I'm 28 years
old hi I'm Dena I'm 30 years old and I'm
from London as
well uh Troy 47 and I'm from London and
I'm a dating coach do you want an
interesting fact I'm 3% Albanian
according to my DNA test 3% Albanian
where are you
C I'm as what w there you go um is it CH
M what's it m she she um Shea what's it
what you saying don't know she my she is
that from the mountain yeah we're all
from the
mountains that's why we're so you
know Adonis 30 years old from New York
City informative content
creator I'll be 41 single and I was
going to say I'm a regular but all these
guys car oh this is everyone's a regular
here oh
yeah I was like oh yeah we do have a lot
of repeats
today this is great yeah yeah go uh my
my name is Nema and uh I have my uh show
in New York City on November 17th
um at City Winery and I also have my new
book on how to not be a
[__] yes yes is that dedicated to
yourself or to women published on dng
who's but is that for men or women that
should be for
men why
they newe you know what's interesting
you know what's
interesting be a man is seen as a good
thing or be a [__] or a woman is seen
as a bad thing yeah true yeah very true
no I don't think I don't think be a
woman is is seen as a bad thing if you
say you're acting like a woman right now
is that usually is that usually good or
bad but if I say you acting like a woman
right now it's usually see a negative
behavior it is
yeah all right go ahead China I mean I
feel like I feel like I've I've my name
is China how how many shows have you
been on at this point or your shows or
just I don't know like can't even count
right I can't count but you
what am I am I regular am I panelist
what am I what am I now am I I don't
know man my name is TR the mum's voice
and yeah everyone I feel like everyone
knows me I just keep going viral every
single day now and and and and yeah it's
it's shout out to all the blogs that
keep posted me um yeah the mm's voice my
name is China on on on YouTube and stuff
so um China I'm so glad you're here
today why is that I am so glad you're
here um I actually decided that we're
going to start the show with a certain
clip that China sent me so you know so
you know um China how old are you just
10 39 okay so you're 39 so I'm seeing
this growing number of older men right
older like around 30 or late 30s early
40s that have never married no that have
been right so you're you're 41 right
you're 30 40 47 39 all of you guys never
married it's interesting right I know
you married but but you got married
later too yeah I got married at 42 and
so you know a lot of times they ask the
question to the men why aren't you
marrying these women you know so why
aren't you getting married and China
just had the funniest
clip you know where he really answered
the question why AR why aren't why
aren't the guys marrying okay go
ahead
[Music]
the answer yeah cuz look at what I got
to pick from look at you
women why went there a riot why went
there
riots
viral that go spinning
around he chose violence he chose
violence he chose
violence he chose violence
he
[Laughter]
I think the first time I saw that I
cried laughing that was so funny where
where was that um that was in Brixton in
event called um shout out to pod and
party noise and B yeah that was the
event and I was a guest and and like you
said they they asked me I got a question
bro bro how do you have the balls the
balls to do that in a full black black
you know what you know what I'm going to
say like you know say it say it say it
do that in a full black environment with
a whole bunch of black women in a black
community and have the B to say that
with you but you was right yeah you have
some points of what you was making but
that's some
balls that's some balls I'll be honest
with you like like like um PA after Paul
was like yeah you're going to need some
security off yeah we're going you
know I he was saying I should come to
the next one I'm like oh God me and
you Omar is coming no like yeah PE needs
to come to the next one but 100% yeah we
going to have some security you expect
did you expect them to go that mental
about it though cuz it seemed fair
enough to me really it
seemed I'll be real with you I was going
to answer it completely differently so
um um you know another lady was a panel
and she from um from my podcast um from
not Notting them and she actually asked
me a question why aren't you married
right and I was trying to explain so I
was about to articulate why I'm not
married and explained all the all my
friends which are my age range which are
doing well which are not married because
of obviously what's going on they
wouldn't let me do that they started
heckling me they started doing that
thing in a in a room full of women oh so
why are so then I was like okay well if
you want they don't want to get that try
they want they want the Menace try so
you went to the ends you went to the
ends of brick what do you expect well
well the truth of the matter is we're in
a post-marriage society most people just
don't know it yet I mean they're
predicting 50% of women um at marrying
age are going to be single and childless
and then on top of that the 50% of women
that do get married half will divorce so
that leaves one and four that'll be with
a guy and their old age you know like
going to be your other
answer um no I I've explained it before
like end of the day look so here's the
thing right I can have accountability
I've made bad choices in the part with
women so that that's the first start I
think men you know but also for us men
we don't really probably get into
marriage mind into your 30s I think you
know I was lit don't get into marriage
at all I was literally thinking about
this this particular um situation you
know getting to my 30s and I'm thinking
like yo um shouldn't I be having kids
getting married at this moment you know
it it hits into place but then I think
to myself is I don't think that marrying
for men for love is the main priority
anymore I think that you have to marry
for business and once you think marri
for business then your perspective
changes not think well you should you
should you should have to mar mar for
business is a bad business you should
you should have to marry for love you
should you should be you should be able
to marry for love but unfortunately I
mean there's no surprise is it that
dudes are getting married less I mean
look at look at the laws look at look at
look at how look at how set against guys
it is and we take away and the other
thing as well is that let's be frank
guys are programmed biologically to to
want to spread their seed okay now I
don't think and I don't think that that
goes away with age personally so you've
got to be very sure that the person that
you're married to no no seriously
seriously no seriously seriously well
you know me me at me at 16 was
completely different than me at 30 me at
16 I'm 47 exactly the same
but I feel like like a lot of my friends
want to get married like you know me I
started this journey very you know like
I said my three sisters married my
brother's married my parents married for
over 40 years that's your culture right
yeah that's my culture where you from
Cameroon um I want to be married is
something it's it's an ideal for me I
won't have babies out of wedlock I don't
I don't doal baby Mas you know I put
that out there right um and I've I've
governed my choices by that but at the
same time I also understand like see I
Men actually want to marry for love and
that's what really messes us up yeah
yeah like because we actually want to
marry for love bro you're 100% correct
but then when it comes down to the
situation you're sitting there you're
looking you're like after majority of
men get married and then the divorce
happens it all comes down to the
business oh I own this house you own
that the bank accounts now it's business
so that's why I say you have to marry
for business you can't marry For Love or
you lose you mean like marri with a
business head if you're if you're going
to marry somebody I I would assume that
the best way at this moment in time
because trial and everal most of the
guys who sit down and get married at any
age at this moment in time once the
divorce happens it's like lawyers why
are you thinking about divor yeah but
what if a woman says that
woman I'll actually I'll actually I'll
actually tell you why they think about
divorce because you know the divorce
rate is between 40 and
50% um dating courtship before man
marriage has extended from average 6
months a 100 years ago to three years
today so it takes you three years to get
a ring um on average um according to Pew
data 63% of men under 30 are s single
and roughly half of them have given up
on relationships and in divorced women
get custody 90% of the time only 20% of
dads get weekly visitation 27% of dads
get no visitation rights yeah so yeah is
it the the reason why it takes longer
for the courtship phase now is because
guys know that they've got a vet more
more properly CU back in the day you
know like when my parents got married it
was pretty much
you know a fate comp ple you get married
you're going to stay together that's it
kind of thing or certainly my
grandparents these days because the
divorce rate is so high and because of
the way the laws are the guy's got to be
very sure that he's R the white right
woman so he's going to spend a lot more
time EXA that woman do and do women
divorce for good reasons typically no so
I'm I'm going to tell you I'm going to
tell you the most frequently cited
reasons are trivial they include things
like emotional disconnect irreconcilable
differences and lack of time together
give away seven reasons though why
they're huh in marriage you only get
seven reasons why you could divorce
someone yeah and you would think they
would be like you know the big things
like
adultery you Paul you know I saw that I
saw the clip you were when you were on
peers yesterday did what was that one
one of the women that told a story about
somebody who was 60 and she divorced her
husband because she she she was like oh
I haven't lived my life I've only
experienced Life as a married wife and a
as a mother and now I want to go out and
experience life differently as a woman I
thought that was an incredibly sad story
oh to you know she spent a lifetime with
her husband and then she's just like oh
I want I want to do the Eat Pray Love
thing oh it's common it's it's not well
I'll say it's not uncommon I mean a lot
of them just did the separation they
didn't like divorce on paper but there's
a reason we're in this mess there's a
reason like why the younger women are so
lost it's because I I really think
there's been two generations of shitty
wives bad wives bad mothers yeah depends
because because um what I see in the
generation above us is they had very
little wife skills a lot of them tended
to work none of them really believed in
obeying and submitting to their husband
so it's like us we don't know anything
then the generation before that um tends
to be women that stayed married they
might know how to sew how to cook but
they didn't have the right mindset
because the propaganda started really
heavy in the 50s and 60s and so they
taught their daughters no you always
have to have a backup plan you have to
work and so you see like the generation
above us which I would say like 40 to
60-year-old women I I call them the
generation of shitty
wives and the 60 and the 60 to 80y old
women stayed married typ more so but
they just passed on like the bad mindset
to their daughters and the when I've
interviewed 80 to 100y old women which
are less you know they die so they're
less and less but but but but they seem
to be a lot more like they believe in
obeying their husband so it seems like
we've actually had not one not two but
three generations of shitty wives no
wonder none of us are making it down the
aisle but as well as well if you're
going to if you're going to get shacked
up with if you're going to marry
somebody you know the whole thing that
the trackon thing that gets thrown at
people when they argue against marriage
a lot is like well you're going to die
alone you're going to be miserable
you're going to be doing a deathbed and
you're not going to have anybody there
and all of that but the thing is if I
marry somebody and then at 60 she she
thinks oh s that I want to go and you
know sew my wild o for for the next
couple of decades I'm going to Dad
anyway so what was the point of it so
when everyone laughed when I said you
know everyone got up and upo oh my God
he said you know who wants to marry you
but essentially they thought that was
talking about the room see the room
represents what's actually out there a
bunch of baby Mas were in there and they
didn't like the fact that I was telling
them that yeah but you are right and
it's going to affect what's going on
right then there's a bunch of women that
are screaming and the heckling me when
I'm a guest and I'm trying to speak
these are all rude things these are very
mascul unfeminine things right well yeah
so when I'm saying to them that oh you
I'm not it's cuz this room represents
some of the women that and and and for
me I'm seeing the women that I would
want to be with a lot of beautiful women
in that room but when you attach the
attitude or you attach all of I'm like
I'm a guest speaker I shouldn't be
getting this energy but I will give the
energy back and because and because
they're giving all of that energy it
just makes you just want to just send it
right back and you send it back in such
a way that it was like Wow and they feel
it inside because yes nobody wants to
marry you because we don't want to deal
with this and me as a man I would rather
be like I'll rather be a 47 year old man
that's got my stuff together with no
kids and no baby mom well you have to
understand a 100 years ago the average
guy got a virgin that was roughly 120
lbs that typically could help him maybe
like 10050 years ago but typically was
like helping on the farm so she helped
him with housework she had all these
recipes from scratch where it's like you
know today the average woman's 170
lbs it's like we can't even do the like
not fat thing you know like we can't
even that's like the bear and then it's
like the average woman slept with it
between five and eight partners and this
is you know and everyone says that's low
so let's be honest it's probably a bit
higher you know like just based on what
everyone says you know China you made a
really great point you know about those
particular character traits and those
particular women the hackling the
disrespect towards your masculinity and
that particular presence when in that
video was dominantly female
there but you chose that particular area
you know you knew going to brickson you
knew that these particular type of I
wouldn't say 100% then that means that
you like more of a if I was to give a
perfect type of new Moder day woman of a
you know not traditional but like a new
modern day woman be like Beyonce see oh
please sorry that's not an example I
think beyon is a perfect example I think
beon let's come back to reality see you
don't think so you don't think there are
independent women who are actually
intellectual who what does independent
mean for you first of all explain what
Independence means for me as a guy in
your perspective cuz we're all talking
from our own expector for me as I can
explain for me as a guy when I look at a
female one of the things that matters to
me is on my worst day can she be there
for me and talking from s yeah as a guy
like I said for me as a guy if as a when
I look for a woman or think about a
woman I need to know is she thinking
about the future or is she thinking
about her emotional now or my worst day
can she be there for me if I want to say
oh I want to build this Corporation and
she going to say good luck or she say
well what's the first couple steps
there's a different type of mentality of
woman and then when I say when I
reference Beyonce I'm not talking about
her star power I'm talking about how she
can look at a corporation or business
and say you want to own title Jay-Z well
this is what we're going to do I know a
couple artists we can bring them here
and work with you to actually become
that massive male masculine figure
that's the type of woman that I believe
in this modern day
generation is outshined I would say at
this moment in time so it's not like oh
it's not realistic no there are women
out here in this world but you just have
to you're not going to find
them
okay how did you say
that China China you got to give me the
spot you got to give me the spot you got
to give me spot I'm not saying I'm not
saying hold hold on hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on the girls the girls
that I'm saying the girls that are
chilling and hanging out the girls that
have this type of character trait
they're not going to be sitting on the
Block in Brick they're going to be in
different
EnV EnV let let me just speak it on
behalf of the girls in Brixton cuz I
love the girls in brickton shout to the
girls in Brion where is Brion
like what so you know what it is yeah
okay chilling on all right so okay so
for what I mean okay so what I okay wait
what's wrong with
brickton
Bri nothing wrong with brixon we just
talking about like babes you're from the
US you can't come to London right now we
talking about demographic Dem so what
what he's done is right he's seen he's
seen all the women right and it seems
like it seems very loud it's a lot of
people said I can't believe you was
there like I don't know how you handle
it yeah yeah a lot of people did say
that to me right and I get it and I get
it right but part of what I'm doing as
the man nam's voice is I believe that
like in the UK not a lot of people
there's a lot it's like crabs crabs in a
bucket crabs in a b right I don't know
how it is over there you chose an
environment where there's a lot of
females having fun so but on podcast
spaces there tends to be this very this
thing where people like to keep their
like what I like about Pearl is Pearl
puts people together and sits people
together not necessarily that you you
might not sit with right so what I do is
PA's got a very big platform and I also
feel myself as a black content creator
that I like to take myself when I go
viral and take my platform to other
smaller platforms and take some of the
things that I've learned and and and
that's what I do so I get my energy and
I and I try to fall in it to little
things so the reason why you're going to
see me somewhere like that because those
I mean I just think all women are pretty
much the same yeah
I wait let me finish let me finish let
me finish I think there's better choices
and worse choices but I've seen I'll
give you an example you know I
interviewed a guy last week right and he
married a girl that was homeschooled and
a virgin and you know what she did she
did [__] his ass up in divorce court
now he hasn't seen his kid in three
years I've seen I've seen women that are
Muslim that did it I've seen women that
are from Africa that did I've seen them
so it really just led me to the
conclusion there's no good women because
I've also seen you know absolute [__]
make really good girl long-term
girlfriends so so my my my thing is I
think there's highrisk women and lowrisk
women you never really know absolutely
look Bri brixon is very gentrified I
mean like my my father was brought was
born near Brixton and you know shout out
to the Brixton massive because it's you
know it's it's a good place it's a fun
it's a fun place but look the point is
if he'd have done that that talk and it
had been in Chelsea do you think it
would have been a lot different probably
not because like one of my best friends
who lives who lives in in in you know
he's from that side of town he lives in
Chelsea he's just been completely
screwed over
by a woman from that demographic who's
basically taken his kid he hasn't got
access to the kid he's been completely
screwed over Reas there's there's but
there's a there's a reason it's a Glo
I'll get to this but there's a reason
it's a global movement it's because
women aren't special we're freaking all
the same but that's a culture that's a
culture that's a culture difference what
I'm talking about with you when it comes
out to you you knew and the reason I
referenced brickson because you know
100% you chilling in the ends you
chilling with the with the with the
community you know what I mean so you
know they going to get but but on some
level is I don't separate myself from
the community so it's like it's like
those are stool my women so they might
be lost or they might be lost they just
you know but part of my job is that I
have to I have to do that and yes it may
come with a Target on my back but at
least got say it so I'm going to I'm
going to answer your question you said
what did he do for the the kid no a lot
of times nothing A lot of times women
just get angry and spiteful and just
decide no no thank you
and yeah and I do understand that I've
um I've got also male friends who's
definitely experienced that but then on
the other hand you do have the men who
will [__] over a woman and turn a woman
into doing such spiteful things so there
need
to I'll get to you wait what do you what
what do you think he would have to do to
deserve to not see his blood DNA okay
right Fair all
right nothing there's no reason there is
no there is there is there all right
hypothetically there isn't no reason for
you not to see your blood
butac no it is unacceptable however
where accountability accountability
accountability needs to be taken is
there are things that men will poke and
keep on doing at a woman remember we are
women we're females yeah we've got
emotions we're not like a male yeah so
we're not going to tolerate we're not
going
tolerate so I have to I have to disagree
with you I I think there is no reason
for a woman to ever like there's nothing
a man can do to deserve that I think
women that do that should like and I I
don't even think we should give them an
out or an excuse like you're poking I'm
no it's not I'm not saying it's an
excuse I'm just giving you the scenarios
which happen a lot of what like what so
in regards to like two people in a
relationship let's say if a guy is
constantly cheating on his woman if he's
constantly disrespecting her if he's
constantly um not showing any attention
why' she make a kid with a
cheater that because the the cheating
exactly you don't know the cheating
either happens after or I I don't I
don't I don't believe it go ahead I
actually to to her point I once had a
niece uh on her 18th birthday she said
maturing is realizing you don't need a
man that's when her father and I looked
at each other in
disgust later that night two robbers
broken to the house and threatened to
kidnap her that's when she screamed and
pleaded for her father and I to come
save
her that's when we took off our our our
our hat and showed that we were actually
the robbers oh my
God but
my hold on hold on hold on but my niece
but my niece learned a very big lesson
that night
don't be a later now she hasn't now she
hasn't spoken to us since
then and now she does only fans
what you sent her over the edge we need
talk about this no but I think a lot of
that but a lot of that is because I
don't think I think she's just too
embarrassed to admit she was wrong and
ladies maybe she doesn't no no maybe she
thinks that that behavior was like
messed up Ladi it's
traumatic for ladies ladies Ladi think
hold on hold on this this is for y'all
this is Alpha King rule number
344 women don't need a man but
statistics have shown if they don't have
one they become bitter overweight and
[__] godamn plus I disagree with that
they're more likely to be
kidnapped take take
it taking two ain't nobody try to kidnap
me with the years I've been single so
you can't say
can't say that there's a lot of there's
a lot of things you have to back up what
the culture of that woman is the way
she's brought up there's a lot of
factors you can't be like oh vulnerable
woman she's been single boohoo her no
I've I've been okay I've been single a
long
time I have a question but then you I
have a question I have a question so
what what happens if someone breaks into
your apartment you I just you think you
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
please go ahead what do you do there's a
few steps I'll take okay okay what's
step one try to be brave and head on and
deal with Omar is in your apartment I'll
try to throw something at Omar I'll be
tactical that's going to fail okay okay
so when that fails what do you do what
do you call the men the Albania men that
come and rescue me how long will that Al
Albania man T to get there when om's so
so we'll find out what okay so you you
do need bad of course I'm not I'm not
disagreeing with that I was just adding
but it's so crazy how confident and
comfortable you know this as a guy as a
guy who sits down in this particular
situation you know every day when I woke
out it's a possibility of getting into a
confrontational situation without me
actually wanting to be in that
particular situation and every day
mentally as a man we are prepared to
deal whatever cons whatever situation
happens you have to automatically think
of the negatives before you think of the
positive while being a man the fact that
you can sit here and say if Omar if me
looking at Omar right now so po so po if
you remember last week um was you was
literally having this conversation with
with the um that was sat over there and
then she was saying oh they would do
this and do that if a man stepped in the
room and all of this stuff and actual
fact oh yeah shout to it was Jazz she
was saying that um cuz King actually
pulled her up and she was like she get
involved her brother was doing something
she'll get involved right um
unfortunately you've heard about that
15y old girl that got stabbed r p I
think her name was was it um was it Iana
rip to 50y oldold iano initially we we
we it was said that she was um stabbed
because by ex-boyfriend but now it's
found that it wasn't even had anything
to do with her she was protecting her
friend protecting her friend yeah it was
a a guy yeah yeah he was a 17year old
boy and she was 15 year old girl and he
stabbed her yesterday but initially it
was um he tried to give flowers but we
thought that he stabbed his girlfriend I
knew there was more to the story that
didn't make any sense okay but what I'm
trying to say is yeah women you you have
to understand violence you don't
understand violence her friend tried to
step in to help because you know but us
men know when you step into help this is
the result yeah and I'm trying to make
you understand when you're talking about
this oh I will do this I will be brave
you don't understand violence bravery
has nothing to do with violence when
Real Men step in Violent Men your life
can be on the line and and the reason
why I want to say this is because women
seem to have some idealistic it's some
imaginary thing about beef I'll do this
I will hit him in the nuts no you won't
you're not prepared you're not going to
do this with real violent people and we
just I need to put that out there's a
lot of violent people out there a man
even as a man we're not prepared or
we're not sure if we actually are ready
for that particular whenever you go to a
man you don't know this is the last this
could be your last breath yeah exactly
it can be and Men understand this right
but women don't realize that they don't
so the only reason I'm saying it to you
my dear like it's only because I
understand I get it but part of the
reason we speak like this is because us
men we understand violence and the ideal
thing women are supposed to be protected
they should have a man in the home they
should have if you haven't got a man you
should have a son in the home because us
men with sons will defend our mothers
um but if you have nobody in your
community to protect you then when you
get in scenarios like this which can
happen ultimately you will start looking
to men because it's not women you're
looking to so that's all I'm saying and
obviously rip to that young girl man
it's just it's so sad so sad so um I'm
curious so back to the the marriage
topic who here thinks they'll be married
raise your
hand all right one two three four five
two so you're already married so King
you're not involved okay okay you two
don't I I don't think so not legally
married okay do you think you'll have
like kids someday it's not top of my
list okay to be honest it's just that's
just a personal thing I think it's a
very personal thing for each each
individual person um you know I get a
lot of push back from that because
people say that your your life is not
complete if you don't have have children
I personally don't believe that I think
that you can make create meaning in your
life with multiple ways I mean Jesus
Jesus did it absolutely absolutely um
but that's just a personal thing and you
know me I've got my nephews and all that
and also I've got this my second family
who've got like loads and loads of kids
that I I've known since birth so okay um
so what makes you guys want to have a
family oh what
ohing I've got a daughter already okay
you've got a daughter U why don't we I
want to start with the men and then
we're going to go to the women so why
don't you start and you you
um I grew up with a single mom and a
brother and a sister and just to watch
struggle but the feeling that to see how
there's a different type of feeling that
you have when you have a child and I can
see other parents have it I can see this
different type of feeling that a feeling
that you just don't experience within
life I want to get married I I want to
have but I have to be very selective I'm
not going to just marry anybody I have
to make sure like I said earlier to you
guys I have to do it for a business it's
not for love I have to think about no
seriously I'm Listen to listen no look
for real I really think about like
I can only I want to marry for love but
for business can we grow a million
dollar Corporation can we I don't start
relationship everything bab it's not
about money you know what is I agree
with you but I just think it's how
you're attaching the it to money
phrasing maybe the yeah it's the phrase
but I you understand what I'm saying
like it's not about for Troy what do you
think of that I well I think it I mean
I'm a bit of an old romantic in a way I
think you should be I I think it's a
shame no no seriously I think it's a
shame that we can't marry for love I
think I think the ideal for me if I was
going to get married I would want it to
be for love and I would but
unfortunately the culture doesn't seem
to support that yeah exactly you know
what I'm saying like I don't want to be
I don't want to be dealing with a woman
and thinking hm you know can we can we
become this amazing power couple are we
going to do the Jay-Z Beyonce thing like
I I don't want to be thinking that I
want be thinking because because I
because I see love as something pure and
something distinct from that but that's
one particular moment in my biggest fear
my I don't know if I don't know if most
women make good business part but you
know
guys guys guys honestly I actually
relate to the black people
here I can actually relate to the black
people here because many women have told
me uh the size of my cck is like a black
man I mean bro pause you have to say
pause you have to say PA you have to say
pause you have to say pause I mean I
mean I I mean I don't know I don't
know how do you respond to that I don't
know exactly how do you respond to that
I mean ladies how do you respond to
that hold no you have to respond to that
you have to respond to that all right
first first I'm just going to say this
I'm no you can't you can't respond to
that you can't respond to that you can't
refer to black people as black people
yeah you can't
ref hold on let me just say this let me
just I love you I swear no homo po or
you know what I mean just but you just
can't ver to black people as black
people it just that's the only thing but
we understand what you're saying we
attention we rock with I don't know man
what what's the obsession with with our
black men's things I don't know man what
is it man you got a lot of you man and
Adam 22 what's up with you man man you
man and Adam 22 man what's up with you
man man you man love our things man we
are going for that so that's a whole
other story isn't it wait okay we need
to get back on back back on to back on
to CH marriage marriage okay so I think
people should I think people should be
able I think the the problem is the
culture is [__] that's the problem
people should be able to marry for love
it shouldn't be this big business thing
it shouldn't be like oh my God like what
what's our 10 year plan going to be it
should be because because I don't know
because that's what love is Love Is Love
Is Love is something that comes in and
it can eventually go in like a month a
year or two years honestly honestly okay
I've I've interviewed hundreds of chicks
hundreds okay I've talked to lots of
entrepreneurs and no even even outside
of that women that make money through
Instagram and um the women that I
actually believe make money like I
believe it talking to them maybe five 10
out of hundreds I think if you're
looking women tend to make terrible
financial decisions actually it's why we
have so much debt I I I think like
honestly if you're looking for a
business
partner so are you saying that you're
not a good business partner I say you
know um I'm a bit of an exception
because I was raised by um a guy that's
extremely successful I don't think most
women come from that there are
exceptions to every rule but what what
women have had the upbringing with 10
siblings and a bunch of entrepreneurs in
the family that were actually like the
people that have achieved my dad's level
of success is like uh 1% half a percent
so okay miracles
happen the other problem though the
other problem though the other problem
though is and my dad helps me a lot too
the other problem though and know he
doesn't bankroll Everything you
ask and Dad Bank of M and Dad the the
other problem is that um that that
having a a woman in your life having a
close relationship with a woman can
sometimes get in the way of your career
aspirations if and you could say okay if
you picked the wrong woman whatever but
I think that in my experience I think
women like the results of the work you
know they like you to be successful they
like the maybe they like the money they
like the fact that You' you've
accomplished certain things they don't
look quite so much like you actually
doing the work so if I say to if I say
to the woman I'm with right this weekend
I'm going to be working I'm going to be
sat in my room I'm going to be writing a
book I'm going to be there 12 hours a
day you can go do your own thing a lot
of the time they're not very happy with
that you know because because they want
because they want the attention so that
that is an actual detriment to my to my
career and even just hiring men and
women it's like women always want
vacation Jesus Christ need vacation they
need vacation they need ghost trip they
need ghost trip look it look it I mean
it's just and I'm not like you know I
I'm not saying there aren't smart
talented women out there I'm not like
there are there are exceptions but they
don't like I'm like if you if you want
as a rule guys looking for a business
partner I'm like i' say that's a
terrible plan I think I I think I think
that if uh if you're with a woman that
supports you in your business and is
like there for you through the growing
of the business and is there to support
you then I think it absolutely can work
and that's
whaton it it work hold let me clar me
let me cl my adice let me clarify this I
grew up I grew up with a I grew up with
a single a single mother but my mother
was a Rada she was literally that type
of woman you know and that's the type of
woman I want a Rada
woman I'm going to be honest with you
wait wait wait King what were you going
to say I think it's they don't make
listen to I listen to what you've said
but I just think you really don't
understand the true nature of women
because the reality
is what you what you what you're saying
you want I think what you should be
asking for is a submissive woman not a
business partner because a business
partner isn't necessarily A submissive
she can be submissive in a business no
no no no because you mentioned Beyonce
and it's funny that you mentioned
Beyonce because you have this perception
that Beyonce is this business mle but do
you actually believe that Beyonce is the
one that has pushed her career to where
it is right now or do you believe she
has a team of men that have helped
her Jay one them hold on knows hold on
yeah exactly that's what I'm saying
don't discredit Beyonce she put a lot of
work in on that she's a talented artist
she's a talented perform Entertainer
don't comp Britney's very talented but
there's a lot of there's a lot of men
around her that push her career but very
but Beyonce is on a whole another level
but my point is if you want if you want
a woman to help you build not help no
but what I'm saying but the word you
said I'm just saying you want a woman to
to build this Empire with yes you don't
want a business partner you want a woman
that will literally support you in
whatever decisions you choose to make
not helping you make decisions no no no
no no just clarify just to clarify my
woman has her own thing that she got
going on I have my own thing that I have
going on and we compromise and meet in
the I'm I'm going to be what happens to
the family what happens to the kids if
she has her own thing going on what do
you mean what to your family what
happens to your home what happens to
your kids we create first of all it's me
and her first and then we create that
into the future who Tak I have to be I
have to be honest so you you would you
would you would take out time from your
own career to help her out the more
successful you get the easier it is for
you to delegate so now you got a nanny
no I'm talking about with the business
talking about with the bus basically
what I'm trying to say to you is I have
to I have to be honest this doesn't
sound like real for real are you serious
sound so hold on hold on so you're
telling me hold on you're telling me
right now you're telling me that you've
never met women who actually do business
are submissive are progressive um I and
I would say miracles happen but I
wouldn't so you think I'm are you saying
I'm in a miracle I I would say most most
women the women that I have met that I
would that I like cuz the the like maybe
10 women off the top of my head that I'm
like okay cuz usually like if you ask
chicks about how they make money it's
like you ask them like two or three
questions it's figure out it's like
nothing and so so the women that I've
met that I would actually believe um I
would say the majority of women that are
successful are pretty masculine um I
would say the majority probably aren't
super submissive I would say again you
know miracles happen I know a couple but
you know on on a balance of
probabilities I just wouldn't really one
of the things hold on before one of the
things I learned about women in general
is that there's a hierarchy of women
okay so women would see you could show a
girl different girls different looks
particular girls some girls will say
she's cute and then some girls say wow I
like her style I like her aesthetic I
Like the Way She Moves cool if you look
for the type of girls that are approved
by certain women then that's the type of
girl you should be going for and I'm not
talking about
sexually hold on you understand what I'm
saying no no no listen listen there's a
hierarchy there's a hierarchy let me let
me give you some I want to some women on
this I some women
wa actually I want to no no no no no no
no hold on hold on okay so let me let me
get this straight
you want the women that are approved by
other women on the hire there's wait
wait wait wait I just need a yes or no
please don't I can't give you I can't
give that's not that's not my stat
please pleas please just please make
this simple don't go on a tangent please
you're turning into woman like okay on
this hierarchy it's women that are
approved by other women on the hierarchy
yes or no no okay okay so then what is
it yeah all right so I've from what I've
learned and let's just give a little bit
of background about me I've worked in
the clubs I was acrobatic dancer I was
artistic director for a couple different
so I've been around the block all right
for multiple different ways you can sit
down and find different types of women
who are visually beautiful the body all
this type of stuff and women will look
at her and be like she's showing her
body up on social media but then you'll
find another woman who doesn't show her
body on social media who has a perfect
type of aesthetic who literally
is well put together and women would say
I like this woman I respect her I want
to follow her I want to see what she's
doing but that's I'm so confused right
now I don't know do you understand what
I'm
saying femes you understand what I'm
talking about wait wait wait wait hold
on guys guys if we're going to go by the
women approved by other women then you
have the most followed women are Taylor
Swift Selena Gomez cardi B Nicki Minaj
no we're not talking about that we're
not talking about that approval oh God
that's reach engagement yeah that's
reach engagement let me that's reach
engagement
understand let me give you some
advice you see do you see how com girl
in the black is and hostile and then
look at the guy and she's not com she's
not com she's not hostile she's not
hostile hold she's exessive okay
everyone H you what h mean stop CH stop
if you all
see wait wait guys wait wait wait wait
China stop chops China stop go ahead and
then and then you can go yeah let's have
some floor respect for each other guys
you know if you see how combative and
hostile the girl in the black
is now if you look at the gay guy on
that side who sitting who's sitting
who's sitting crisscross applesauce more
he's more feminine than her hey what's n
okay wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait please wait please please wa China
China stop okay go ahead go ahead you
I'm going to let you go so what um what
I was saying is exactly what you just
explained in regards to the women on
Instagram and the prum proper she
literally just named two two sets of
women Selena Gomez Taylor Swift That's
the prim proper one cardi B and niage
those entertainers those are
entertainers oh my gosh there're still
women they are still women it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what they do for a living no stop
it doesn't matter what they do for a
living we're just speaking either you're
trying to understand or you're not
trying to understand there's a
difference understand no I I wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait okay okay thank
you thank you you're just making no
sense but we're just
going okay wait wait let me speak cuz
I'm trying to speak to bro cuz I got
some years on you bro and you know what
you're doing you're doing what women do
when they try to build a b like an like
an Like An Invisible Man like they'll be
like I want a man that's emotionally
ready for me I want a man that's six
foot I want a man to be six figures then
I want a man to be a killer then I want
a man to also write poetry then I want a
man to sing then I want a man to rap
like what you're doing is so what do you
look for in a women no because what do
you look for in a woman no wait wait
wait it's no no it's not I'm curious I
want to know you got me wait listen
educate me canate
hold chill life hasn't smacked you in
the
face how can I educate you if you're not
listening I'm ready so what I'm trying
to say to you is yeah your job is not to
build with a woman like that bro you're
if you want to do that you need to pick
pick her in your in your teens you're
now in your 30s now you're supposed to
have it built you're not supposed to
talking about I'm supposed to get a
woman a woman at this point is not
supposed to hold your hand I know I I
know it feels like you want it to happen
cuz I want it to happen too but at this
point in your life you need to go build
and then have something ready for her to
come and she can add on to it you don't
need to start saying you know what you
need to start going because it's
sounding like 50/50 it's sounding like
you want to bring a woman Inside to help
build your dream but you're not supposed
to do that wait hold on the man is
supposed to lead so when she finds you
you're supposed to Leading her you're
talking about I want a woman to build
with and build an Empire all she needs
to do is be a submissive Good Wife and
able to Bear your children and that's it
and you need to do the rest my guy there
go can I respond can I respond
thanks CU that resp that was very on
point can I respond of course I mean I
respect that I respect that point of
view you know but right now we're living
in 2023 were women a lot more capable
than they once were oh don't do that bro
cuz you're you're going to feed the
feminism with this bro basically you're
saying y this is what the feminists live
of we are capable we don't need no men
so you want a masculine
woman digilant and masculine two
different things no no no no no no no
I'll be honest with you what you're
asking for hold on I can't come back two
people at the same time hon I'll be
honest can I can I me you have a
conversation real quick hold hold on
hold hold okay okay wait wait wait wait
oh my gosh okay it's
like he's making a good point wait wait
wait wait Waitz I wait for while wait
China wait wait okay I'm going to let
you go and then you can go and then you
can go all right all I'm trying to say
right yeah you're you're doing your
thing you're you're you're on your bag
now you're building right all you really
need for a woman is to respect you and
to see your vision right then she'll
come and support your vision but what
you don't need to do is start making a
woman feel like she needs to build your
vision and that's what I'm trying to say
so the language you was using was
looking like you know what I want a
woman to come and I want to help me and
if she doesn't see all she really has to
do is just be with you and believe in
you that's enough that's enough you're
100% right and and I know it's 2023 and
I know women don't disagree with you
independent get in their bag but
sometimes us as men we need to allow a
woman to get into a feminine and be like
you know what actually I'm going to
trust you and how can we lead as men if
we keep saying one half you know what I
want a woman want to cook I wanted to do
this submit and then the other half were
like you know I wanted to come and pay
the bills and come invest in my business
bro hold on I agree with you 1,000% cing
backwards hold on I agree with you 1%
but majority of the women I engage with
they they're already well the majority
of I used to engage with they're already
doing their own thing they're already
moving and in motion I've been a 4year
relationship so that Dynamic and that
mentality is already instilled she has
her thing I have my thing and that's
what I want I don't want a girl that's
just not going to do nothing you know
you know what interesting I kind of I
kind of see where you're both coming
from okay cuz hear me out hear me out
one I think this business partner sorry
that's that's stupid to me that's like
the dumbest thing we in terrible
business um no offense but but on the
other hand I do understand where he's
coming from with like guys don't want a
girl that's just doing nothing true you
know um like I think in and it doesn't
have to necessarily be like a job but
you don't want to ever date someone
that's lazy you know true true I I think
the worst thing in the world is to be
dating a woman who's just sitting around
on her phone and just doing but at the
same time the same China China you want
that I'm going to be honest with you
your hold on a second whenever we do
this this is like when women say like oh
you know what he's like bro none of us
in never in my life have I ever linked a
waste woman of a girl that does nothing
it's never in my life so it's sounding
like it come on bro it sound like that's
your default I'm going keep it real it
sound like it's your default no no I
don't think so I don't think so my thing
is this yeah well you I mean I think you
just I think China's I think China's got
no his point is correct he's got a good
point about this I dat boss bro I spoke
about boss listen
listen no don't make me tell you about
my baddies and what they got bro don't
don't do this like like here's the thing
I've dated women that got everything
they don't need nothing from me I've
dated baby Mas that got everything all
they want is a man because they got
everything they divorced they got their
business there's a lot of women that are
in their bag that are doing their thing
bro all I'm saying is when I meet these
women I don't say to them you need to
invest in my business that's not what
I'm saying but don't imply I'm saying
that say she don't got to do nothing
other than be a boss [__] that's it
have your pece have your stuff and then
that's it yeah but that's not what I'm
saying though no but it feels like no it
doesn't matter what it feels like I'm
telling you that's not what I'm saying
what are you saying tell me what are you
exactly saying cuz you it's kind of
confusing cuz based off what you just
said just to clarify based off what you
said is we're on the same type of path
boss [__] I don't want to say boss
[__] but women women who are
successful yeah boss women women who are
successful who have their own passion
their own thing that they got they're
driven indigen on their own job that's
more that's what more I'm interested in
those type of particular women but why
would you not be here I thought
or you want to be with the woman you
want to be with the woman who's got
stuff going on but in terms of in Terms
that's not what it sound like it sound
like it sound like you guys wanted a a
regular de chill in the house wash clean
don't do nothing and you come home no
one wants that no terms even even if I
do and even if I do want a regular de
just chill at home what is wrong with
that that's not what I want though okay
look I mean I just I have a question I
have a question to the men so um I know
a chick these women are rare but she was
homeschooled okay she didn't go to
college she just works a part-time job
and what she does is she's at home and
she she knows about she has her own like
recipe book makes like 20 different
meals from
scratch um she works she works with
children so part-time job is like I
think she works as like a nanny or
something would you PR prefer that or a
career woman I prefer that I think but I
think ultimately
if you bring it if you bring it back to
this question about marriage because
what we're talking about here is who
would you who would you choose as a life
partner you going to get legally
contracted to for me personally I think
it's got to be somebody who's kind of
got to just step out the way as far as
the business stuff's concerned I don't
think they should be involved I think
they should give you the time and the
space and the focus that you need to
work on your stuff now if she's doing
her own thing you know in our own right
absolutely fine because you're right I
don't want to be with some girl who's
just doing you know s all and she's just
looking at
but I do think that the most important
thing and I personally in my own life I
found this quite difficult to find is a
woman who will give me that time and
give me that space in order to do the
stuff that I need to do in order to
build myself yeah I completely respect
that it works both ways I think the most
important thing is no matter how much
how successful a woman is no matter how
much of a boss woman she is what is most
important is that the moment you're
getting married to a woman she needs to
be able to at that moment put family
before her career yeah yeah because the
fact that she's been able to be
successful up to that point just shows
that yes she's hardworking she has good
values but there's a problem when even
in marriage she's still trying to pursue
her career to the highest points cuz
then that affects the children that
affects the the good of the home and
that's the point we're not saying we
want women that are just lazy and don't
do [__] but the point is she needs to be
able to understand her role in the
family I want to so so I want to I want
to pull up a clip of me from Pierce
Morgan yesterday because it kind of
talks about
this um I'm going to pull it
up and then we'll do the the Tweet Pearl
actually actually real quick uh if I may
just before we start I see your shirt
there and uh I actually disagree that
women shouldn't vote I met a [__] once
actually actually sorry she has some
nice tits and good I don't I don't want
to call her that I met a girl
woman and uh she actually wasn't that
stupid so overall uh I agree with your
shirt are you confused like I'm
confused you guys over the same place
see what got it's imposs it's impossible
to get Pearl laugh that [__] is the
hardest this makes me like 10 episodes
but finally sh okay let's pull up the
let's pull it up let's pull it up that
was
hard
welcome back to P sens we model Emily
rowski one of my favorite dimwits SP
controversy claiming they getting
divorced before 30 is
Chic so it seems that a lot of ladies
are getting
divorced before they turned 30 and as
someone who got married at 26 has been
separated for a little over a year 32 I
don't think there's anything better if
there is nothing better than being in
your 30s still being hot maybe having a
little bit of your own money figuring
out what you want to do with your life
for all of those people who are stressed
or feeling stressed about that about
being divorced like it's a it's it's
good
congratulations it's like
congratulations God she's ridiculous uh
well divorce is certainly becoming more
common and marriage itself is becoming a
fierce Frontier in the Raging culture
wars on the one side feminists rejecting
a daty concept on the other so-called
tradwives you think it binds our
societies together well tradwives spend
their days due to the cooking and
cleaning while the husbands go to work
ese Williams who's a 25-year-old Trad
wife has amassed hundreds of thousands
of followers by showing off her Trad
wife life online she even gave up a job
to be the perfect wife so is she and
others like her saving Society or are
they selling out The Sisterhood well J
me now his traditional wife and
influencer EST Williams and in my studio
of socialism author Grace Blakeley and
YouTuber Pearl Davis this might be the
best lineup in the history of Television
for a a debate of this nature so I'm
very excited all right es Williams let's
start with you as the the Trad wife sell
it to me why do you think we should all
go back to having tra wives in
marriages um well I believe that well I
actually don't believe that everyone
should be a traditional wife I think
that it is a choice and and I think it's
a lovely choice if a woman wants to
Simply Be a wife and a mother and that's
enough for her and it's it's a simple
way of living with traditional gender
rules um it's balanced and we don't have
to do it all as women I think we've
proven that um it's possible but at what
cost right right and and in terms of
what being a Trad wife
involves what do you think it means to
be a tradwife
wife well to adhere to traditional
gender roles so what I mean by that is
the husband he is the provider of the
home he goes out he works and he he he
knows how to protect his family if need
be and the wife she's the Homemaker she
does the cooking she does the cleaning
and she takes care of the home and
children if there are any and um herself
of course so that's it's adhering to
traditional gender roles
okay grace I'm sure you thoroughly agree
with this he look I mean what um what
just said about the fact that women
should be able to choose obviously I
completely agree and you know men should
be able to choose as well I think the
feminist critique of traditional gender
roles and gender ideology isn't that
some people like to stay at home and
others don't it's that you shouldn't be
bound to pursue a certain life based on
the sex that you were born into at Birth
the one issue I do have is I know
actually um someone a friend of mine
whose sister got got involved in the
tradwife movement in the US basically
and she was quite young she got married
to someone who was like this is what
we're doing you're going to be a TRD
wife and basically came to regret it um
she felt like she'd been controlled like
her life became very small and she
couldn't get out she couldn't escape
because you know she'd lost all her
friends and and this has become
basically her entire life and it
concerns me uh that sometimes we see
this narrative on social media that
women have to be a certain way in order
to get a husband um so you have to be
this like particular model of femininity
for people to love you and I think
that's really sad because I don't think
anyone should have to shave off any
parts of themselves to be loved or to to
you know find a husband or you know
anything like that all right PA what do
you
think um I think it's I I think it's a
good that we're seeing a return to
traditionalism yeah I think it's a good
thing
how decades wait wait I keep going gone
for you and when you look at it and see
how women have progressed do you think
it's been largely a Force for good or do
you think as the tradwives did perhaps
we've lost that sense of gender rules
from one of a better phrase which
actually worked very well for I mean I
mean we've seen families disappear you
know um I saw a study the other day that
said only 25% of I mean this is an
American step an American household to
have family so um I guess there's
positives and there's negatives but it's
like at what cost you know 80 like 85 um
150 years ago the average woman had
seven kids 85% of people were married I
mean you know that also higher
imortality women died very young and you
know I mean women were more depressed
than ever before we're on
anti-depressants um women over the age
of 45 are the least happy demographics
there are a lot of very the issue is
complex reasons for that I think and the
issue you have is women like Emily
Rakowski you know marriage again I've
said this before marriage isn't marriage
anymore the average marriage is seven
years we have things like no fault
divorce leave if you're unhappy so what
does that mean marriage isn't marriage
anymore because there have been so many
marriages over course of history where
people have been very unhappy either the
man or the woman has been very unhappy
and they've been forced basically to
stay in a marriage it could have been an
abusive marriage could abusive marriage
Mar was we have one life why would you
spend it with
someone the problem we have with women
like women men tend to be better people
than us yeah they really do they tend no
they they tend to do the right
thing I agree I mean there's a reason we
have phrases like a man of his word
right not a woman of her word because
men men will actually stick things out
women when sck gets hard we just leave
and you're proving you're proving my
point what was what was your what was
your first answer my happiness right of
course everyone to be happy the family
doesn't work when it's about you it's
supposed to be about your kids and
that's the pro that's the
problem there's a balance and a
compromise in relationship am I allowed
to talk now
or you been interruped all time about
knowing understanding yourself learning
to you know no understand another person
eventually potentially if you want to
Bringing children into the world and
teaching them how to do that as well
teaching them to balance a sense of
their own identity with the love that
they have for for another person and you
know for example I know um an older
woman actually is a friend of our family
who um got divorced at about 60 she had
you know this lovely family they were
together since they were 18 and she said
I got to a point after I'd stopped being
a mother and you know I was just kind of
getting on I realized I'd lost my sense
of who I was and I didn't really feel
like I knew who I was anymore because
I'd always just been a wife and a mother
and I wanted to go out and explore that
and I think that's fantastic what is
traditionalism um I don't know what you
think TR I would say I would say a
modern mentality is me before the family
I would say traditional traditionalism
is the family before me especially in
women and so and so and so what I
actually it's interesting you said 60y
olds cuz you know I've interviewed 6700
people roughly in the past year and a
half I've done hundreds of shows
interviewing people about relationships
and what I find the 60-year-olds tend to
a lot of those women LED their daughters
astray you know there there's a reason
we're in this mess right a lot of those
women had the wrong mentality when it
came to marriage and had exactly the
mentality that you're talking about
which the one prioritize balancing one's
own sense of identity with compromise
and relationship myself before the
marriage but that's again and it's
really unfortunate because I would say
the women of Our Generation really are
are suffering because of the advice of
the women of the past there's an
interesting point here right which is
that we do live in a very very
individualistic society and we're all
told actually I think a lot of the time
in our relationships as well you have to
be a certain way if you want to receive
love you have to abide by these these
Norms you have to be a certain level of
attractiveness you have to earn a
certain amount of money it's all about
you and that's not what love is let
bring all right listen it's actually be
very interesting to let me bringing back
in EST in terms of TR values Like My
Wife puts the bins out for example right
I don't I've never asked her to she's
just adopted that role in our house so I
never put the bins out I don't know if I
should feel ashamed of myself I do other
stuff but I don't put the bins out as a
Trad wife do you put your bins out is
that part of the gender rule of the 50s
is that what used to happen or does the
man supposed to do that I mean how do
these rules work in
reality to be honest it it has nothing
it I don't want to say nothing it
doesn't necessarily have anything to do
with the 50s and the 60s um especially
in our household I I enjoy the aesthetic
um and I think that's where people get a
little mixed up with my channel but um I
well to answer your question actually I
I don't put the trash bins out my
husband does that but I think we we have
this um this thing in our household
where he does most of the outdoor work I
do all the indoor work of course he
works and provides and I'm the Homemaker
that's what works for us in relation to
in relation to what right in relation to
what Pearl said is is part of a sense of
being dutiful and having no problem
actually with being dutiful in a
marriage uh yes I believe that
traditionalism can it it is putting um
your family before yourself and I think
it it is
um it is having those Traditional Values
that were once definitely more in place
in um God family and love and we live in
a very selfish Society now you know you
see self-love printed everywhere right
and um women i' speaking of divorce and
marriage women are leaving marriage far
more easy easil than uh men and they are
um doing it because they think there's
something better out there for them that
the grass is greener on the other side
and they're finding out that is wrong
and they're going through divorce after
divorce and um you know marriage is a
bond and it's a sacred Bond where to
become one under God and that's
beautiful and you have to protect that
at all costs and and I think part of
that is putting your partner's needs
before your own every single day and I
try and do my best and I think of my
husband as much as I can and what will
please him and make him happy so I
wanted to we can cut it now sorry
obviously I don't I wouldn't dare to
express opinion a lovely way to think
about relationships if it's so I wanted
I wanted to cut it there and I wanted to
point something else out that you might
have gone over some people's heads what
was the biggest difference between the
feminist next to me and the tradwife we
have to answer that question with logic
first what makes a woman a woman her
ability to suck
cop what makes now now what makes now
what makes a traditional life a woman
who sucks Co trying to get now is it now
is it anti now is it anti feminist for a
woman to Su I need to say something no
exactly okay so what right so so the
answer to the question is no okay so
what makes a woman a woman is an adult
true true feminism is a bur true true
true feminism is a burning desire for
cop okay and the same goes for the role
of a traditional wife wait wait hold on
a second guys but bro you keep talking
over everybody be like you going to let
other people talk or not like is it just
your show or or whose show is it bro
honestly
serious you do like have some respect
for other guest it's like eight people
it's not just you bro BR I'm going to
have to answer that first of a little
respect you want me to just keep talking
over
you homie just keeps talking over
everybody bro like are we going to have
FL rules we going to have respect you
don't respect no raising your voice at
me you don't respect
noing your voice at
me you're raising your voice you're
raising your voice you're raising your
voice why are you guys guys guys we need
we need to all
right listen bro you're talking about
you're talking about have to cut your M
respect can can we can we pull it
together one
he's being a bully he's being a bully
being you're bullying the whole group
bro are you a victim what's wrong with
you like I'll let you talk but you
keep's calling me a bully bro I keep
talking over you but you keep talking
over me CH just let him let him get no
but no no no I'm just saying okay guys
guys guys man violate cut off
guys you're having a man screaming at me
just call me a bully and you're cutting
off my mic I haven't done anything guys
guys guys guys guys I love how the women
are nice and quiet and chill loving life
peace and love this is traditional women
right here tradition this all right can
I can I get the room please all right um
pear can you continue the show pleas
think
weent a man bul me Bully Me online like
like like how's a man going to do all of
that you won't even you but but we're
trying to call everyone to other so if
if both it's not you I cut his mic and
yours so it's because both of you no
relax it's because try list trust me
listen to this I'm relaxed it but you've
had a man talk listen everybody Super
Chat super chats
later wait hold on super chats I want
the super chats to to to speak about
what's happened now because you're going
to have me acting like I'm acting mad
I'm actually moving very calm bro I'm
moving very but we need to get to the
show that's the problem so if if if if
PE is calling your both your attention
I'm calling both your ATT both of you
are not listening what do you want me to
do I respect I respect a lot good so
that's ch ch ch it's just I'm just
trying to move on I'm try was I
understand what just
said excuse me excuse me excuse me can
you guys literally just stop please like
I'm I'm trying to I'm trying to like
make a point okay so it's okay so so the
one the one thing that I was going to
say that I I noticed with that clip do
you guys remember the clip that we just
watched okay you guys remember so um I
the biggest thing that I noticed was
female
narcissism because the one woman was
thinking about her husband and the other
woman couldn't like like she literally
thought that I was interrupting her when
when she was interrupting me the whole
time you know what I mean and the first
thing she said was I can only give if
it's reciprocal I think it was but when
when you're in a traditional family unit
it's not about you right just do you
just do right and when you think of the
most like femin like who you I'm sure
you guys have a grandma Aunt whoever is
she counting like oh I did this much for
and that's like so usually when women
say oh I can only do it like I can't be
unreciprocated like it says more about
her I think he was a very sad thing
really I mean I think I think Grace is
actually very attractive she's probably
more attractive than the the tread wife
but and I'm not a big fan of tread wives
generally I think the whole thing is a
little bit corny I think it's a bit
cheesy I don't really buy it I don't
really buy it having said that I think
that the um the tread wife on that clip
I think she was talking a lot of sense
and I think what Grace was saying it was
actually really sad I mean the story
about the 60-year-old woman who just
ditched her husband because she felt
like she wanted to go and find herself I
think that's a terribly terribly sad
story I really do and and equally the
whole Emily rikowski thing it's just
sort of like I mean even putting
families aside what about the bond
between the man and the woman right
you've Fallen presumably fallen in love
with this woman you're like right this
is us we're together it's ride or die
you and me babe and then five years
seven years later the woman's just like
oh actually do you know what there's a
whole like Green Pastures out there so
so you and then she just buggers off and
then and then you wonder why people are
guys aren't getting married but why
would I get married when the light
prognosis of that marriage is that in 7
to 10 years the woman's just going to go
do you know what actually Chad the pool
boy is quite cute I think I'll just uh I
think I'll just ditch this I think why
would I make why would I make a legal
contract around that also depend on how
long they've been together prior to them
obviously getting married like to think
that not
necessarily I want I want to hear what
she said say that again um yeah so I
would like to think that how long that
you're together before the engagement
before the marriage plays a big part so
a big part in What big part in actually
the whole marriage like staying together
for a certain period of time um knowing
like for the lady for example she's just
said after what five years she just said
yeah no forget it basically yeah clearly
to me that seems like you's W you you
haven't been with your partner for a
long time it might be worse it might be
worse if you've been together before CU
then you got more time to get born of
each other I I think problem there
there's a main problem cuz like I mean
I've got a master's degree in Psychology
so I'm kind of just kind of dissecting
of things all that we're seeing is very
self-centered very egoistic
conversations ey this I that there's a
lot of expectations and and the whole
picture pictured on you know the image
of what a perfect man or woman should be
the problem that we're having is no
one's turning around to be like how can
I improve myself how can I better myself
what can I do to be a better person
today or or a better wife or a better
husband there's a lot of external
factors instead of internal factors well
I guess the tread woman's doing that we
need to I guess the tread woman's trying
to do that isn't she the tread woman is
trying to be she's doing that do you see
do you see how that instills like a form
of anxiety between all men this whole
idea like that you can be in a
relationship for 10 years and then next
thing you know she ups and leaves
in gu but it works both ways guys but
women more than men wom divor women
divorce more than men hold on hold on
hold on women divorce you've had your
say let me just say something because I
haven't said anything for the whole like
so basic yeah and then you can reply uh
basically Wom women yes maybe divorce
more with women however what about we
were talking earlier about um when a
woman sort of helps build with a guy and
then when the guy dumps her and he's
successful and then he finds someone
else or he like toy girl or whatever you
know the next the the next young pretty
thing he that girl has that's like
that's like propaganda to be honest seen
so even I mean you might have seen
exceptions but no no I'm I'm telling you
like the numbers don't back you up wom
wom you you can actually you can you can
you can no no no I'll give you I'll tell
you I'll tell you you can actually you
can actually look up like the age that
like people divorce on average and who
files where and women actually even I
mean you can it's usually like you can
get them divorce websites yous well you
you can I'm telling you you can get them
from the UK the US they they're usually
similar we really believe so so I mean
but I mean we can also just look in
normal reality when women go on Tik Tok
and talk about why they got divorced you
know I'm the I'm the biggest one to not
believe stats but I I think you kind of
have to look at what you see in reality
absolutely and and and the truth of the
matter is you could even look at numbers
um like from before the 60s and you can
also because another way you can like
look at what's going on in the times is
you take eyewitness accounts so like um
people that were alive during the time
what they wrote about and women were
more likely to divorce even before no
fault divorce like when it happened
can I add to that before I mean when
we're comparing to 100 years ago and
today let's look at a lot of factors
like let's look at the food that we're
eating the products the hygiene products
that women are using there's a lot of
chemicals we've got a lot of in
imbalance in our chemicals in our bodies
today which function our perspective our
mentality we I me both well we're we're
both kind of messed up the men and the
women I I totally agree that's why we're
so fat so [__] in their head maybe
yeah yeah no I I I totally I totally
agree with you hgs f
is right but but my point is women tend
to file for a divorce and the idea that
like men tend to leave for younger women
women file uh 70 80% of the time so
women like men aren't really filing for
divorce like that and then if you just
want to look in like reality there's
reasons that men say it's cheaper to
keep or happy wife happy life it's
because they're not really divorcing
like that you know owski divorced uh uh
why
yeah I don't agree yeah I don't agree
that she just is like glamorizing um
divorce cuz I think it is a contractual
agreement I've said this before and and
actually that Trad wife woman said it as
well if you are going into a legally
binding contract of marriage you are you
must be thinking about it you can't you
have to have some kind of discernment
that you're like this has to be like
someone that I want to build a future
with otherwise what are you doing unless
you're a gold digger or um or you're
marrying for some kind of fun or
whatever it is other than that like
exactly and I mean I mean it was MIA
Khalifa who said something similar
wasn't it a couple of months ago made it
similar to kind of video and I think I
think where Grace was was wrong is to
say if you're actually marrying somebody
and then seven years down the line you
just change your mind I think that's
wrong because you've entered into a
legally binding like legally and morally
and morally binding contract if you're
just dating them that's a different
thing if you guys are just dating okay
fine but why actually get married and
the and the other thing too is she said
what about your happiness but it's like
why are you relying on someone else to
make you happy exactly never do
that the problem with the problem is
life is is very long and there's a lot
of ups and downs and I mean you're not
going to be happy the whole time and the
issue is that I think some women you
know they get into the relationship it
goes a little bit flat for a while and
then they're like oh [__] the grass is
greener okay let's let's just check out
of this and we'll go go and try over
there and like the tread wife said I
mean the grass isn't always greener you
know um but but I think there's external
factors as well that can come into I
mean the economy the the financial state
that somebody's living in does that
deter someone's uh well if he's aoke if
he's a broke boy she should leave him
yeah
but let's just let's just ask this hyp
hypothetical question let's say there's
someone that's very wealthy and then all
of a sudden the economy crashes and then
what all the chicks Just Bounce okay is
that you got build again you got to
build I'll tell you I'll tell you so we
actually we actually take um this is why
I say men are better people yeah okay
yeah because like when women for example
when women win the lottery women tend to
leave their husbands where men tend to
stay with their wives keep them happy
makes sense when women get promoted
they're they're more likely to divorce
like I mean it's the same that's why I
say women are the same we have the same
Trends and patterns not I mean not every
woman does the same thing but every
woman has an inclination to do the same
is that e do you think we have more of
an eager than men materialistic maybe
ego I mean I just think we're hardwired
to want men that provide for us yeah and
I and I think a lot of times when we
start to out earn them we think they're
better that we're better than them
usually we're in useless jobs yeah yeah
yeah cuz you I mean I'll even use myself
as an example it's like I talk into a
microphone and but I see like I saw a
woman with my same job she was like a TV
presenter I don't know if you guys ebony
Williams maybe you and she's a 39
40-year-old TV presenter which is what
talking into a microphone so like and
she was talking about she wouldn't date
a bus driver but when you think about it
a bus driver is a more necessary job
talking into a
mic um so the last the last thing I
wanted to bring up today actually was um
so back to like the narcissism point
right and what I see is this extreme
narcissism and men just telling us what
we want to hear and one of the themes I
I just kind of think of things as like
patterns and Trends and one Trend I see
is men convincing women that were just
young forever and hot for a
lifetime yeah so um I wanted to show you
guys a tweet that I had that just really
ruffled some feathers and you guys can
tell me if you think it's too offensive
or don't feel don't feel like you have
to hold back okay um so I said we pulled
this up the the do the last one I sent
you I think it's
the the wait wait hold on
it's
follow the the no yeah okay okay so I
had I had a tweet and this tweet had why
wives and mothers tweeting me their
selfies I said no 35-year-old women
aren't that hot ouch none will compete
with the average in shape 21y old don't
shoot the messenger so I want to know
and so this is the response
I'm so basically she just gave us the
keys how to get the women okay okay so
so no wait wait guys please guys wait I
want to ask the women this question am I
wrong
it's debatable for me do you know why it
is I've seen some really good looking 35
year old women on Twitter okay as well I
have I have seen you've seen some
goodlooking 35y old women and they
typically are more good-looking than the
average 21-year-old like we go to a
college campus and those 35-year-old
women are just it's going to be two
different things though isn't it because
at the end of the day a 35 year old
woman's probably going to be more
wrinkled no not at all
money
but look they're gonna have a question
are the 35-year-old women more wrinkled
than the 21y old
women depends it depends I'm going to go
with the women first then I'm going to
come to the guys depends I I personally
feel like it depends okay you obviously
all right cool we're not talking about
going out to do anything to your face or
like that okay yes the 21y old woman
will old can I just say so I work with
clubs and and also I do some stuff
around like student stuff right and um
I've seen students and I've seen the
young kind of girls going to clubs at
the moment no because they don't look
after themselves they're not hot they're
remember I said wait wait wait wait
let's read it again go back up the
average can I just no no no I said the
average in shape because it doesn't
count if we're like like fatties they
don't count you know what I mean like
fatty like we all know a fatty at 35 and
a fatty at 21 men don't want like like
we're not come on like fatties don't
count so I said the average you know cuz
it's like they would be hotter they just
ruin their beauty right but also there
are a lot of like um sort of 21 year
olds that haven't got like a style yet
they haven't got yeah they haven't found
themselves they don't I have a question
I have a question I have a question do
men usually really care about your
style do how do how you okay degree
until they want to take the close off
yeah I mean our men usually is that the
determining Factor your style well it's
the whole package isn't it no they want
to see if your ass look fat in the
sundress exactly okay okay so so okay so
back even care about wrinkles you just
want
ask let's go guys guys chel wait wait so
so so we go back to am I Am I Wrong is
this is this go back please go back up
no I don't think you are I think I love
the fact that you got reality and humor
in one tweet and I appreciate that so
you know we they always bring me up JLo
but it's like [__] are you
JLo and it's like I don't you know like
I mean come on okay sure a 9.5 in her
prime is going to be a seven at
35 but like you know and you know what I
you know what and I I got such a
visceral reaction I had a very similar
one where I had wives and mothers
tweeting their selfies at me and then
putting and then pictures of myself to
prove that they were hotter that they
were just hotter than me and there and
then I had women calling me bitter and
just evil when really my only point is
35-year-old women used to have a family
and they cared more about their
character rather than their looks and it
wasn't the end of the world that there
was a new round of 22y olds and so to me
this spoke more to female
narcissism
because we can't hear you know I'm I'm
26 right and at 26 100 years ago they
would have said you're an old
ma now I understand I understand we're
in
2023 where that's not the norm but I'll
still say you know the average
20-year-old chick is going to be hotter
and that's okay it's not you know I
didn't say bad person I didn't say ugly
and I also put I was very specific I
said that hot because what does that hot
mean that's like pretty sexy by 35 you
should be more beautiful why your ass
out there's women that are really hot
and then they open their mouths and it's
like it's like 35 you're supposed to
kind of put it away like we're supposed
to like age you know like dress a little
less [__] you
know but you know what's so very
interesting every time we have this
episodes here I always learn something
new from listening to women speak and
they always tell on themselves it's just
like you said it women are really really
actually all the same yeah they might be
very it varies they are worse and they
better but they all have the same
program you think about it like this I'm
very sure now that most women don't
actually know what men want from women
because the reality is the men that
women claim they want that's the top
quality men those kind of men are not
looking for your total package in fact
those kind of men want to be the men
that discover a gem that's hidden so if
you're someone that already knows all
your style you already know this that
only signals to the man that you want
that you've been around the block but
men like the journey as well the whole
process no you're literally telling me
what men want or what men like I'm
telling you the fact that the kind of
men you want the kind of men that you
would look at and be like yes I'm glad I
got this man he's not looking for some
woman that is completely packaged and
she knows her style she's in her baby
girl era no that's not what they want
they want to literally discover a gem
that no one has found yeah diamond in
the rough so Nema you had you had you
had thoughts on this yeah I mean so
women are tweeting their selfies to you
to prove they're hot because you
publicly said younger women are hotter
how dare I wow um okay so uh younger
women have prettier
[__] my Twitter is Neo yam
how wow this how old are you 43 so why
do you need to be worrying and also why
do you want to see other exactly things
are you not married exactly are you not
married this is this is a a bad example
of a a guy that I would want to Mar I'd
rather be on my own with cats well I
mean statistically you're going to
be bring it bring it if that's my choice
I'm done I mean statistically only one
of us is going to make it look around
you're right though PE it's about the
narc it's the narcissism of the age
isn't it the narcissism of of women
specifically in this case where it's
like why is it so why is it that these
days every woman has to be hot why is it
I've got to be hot I've got to be
[__] sexy I've got to be like what's
wrong with cute why not just be cute why
not just be cute why not be int why is
it not acceptable to be introverted or
bookish or a little bit nerdy or
whatever what is every single woman it
has to be about this hotness and and not
just when they're young but as they go
into their 30s their 40s their 50s you
know it just seems like yeah what
happened to growing old gracefully and
just accepting the the point in your
life that you are at want to lose
control they don't want to lose control
I think that women get to a point where
you know they're the hottest they've
ever been maybe 1920 and every guy's
talking to them they can't walk down the
street without a guy coming and say
hello to them and then once you get over
to 35 you stop getting those compliments
they always competing with the guys with
without compliments my life is still
blessed I don't need someone else to
give me validation if you're so secure
Within yourself a parents can only do so
much for you darling a parents the fact
that you had to reply to that the fact
that you had to reply to that what
somebody see otherwise can I ask you a
question if you got dressed up here and
you went out yeah for a whole week I'm
talking about in a general perspective
okay if a woman's dressing up for a
special occasion and she's feeling a
certain way fine but not every single
day no one ever recognized you you see
if when you walked out and you was like
invisible and like you just no one saw
you at all How would how would that make
you feel even better you would it's
giving pretty privilege no no no
you would you're missing my point here
I'm just saying we don't always need um
outside kind of validation the fact of
the sorry the fact of the matter is you
can go out like honestly if you've ever
seen me walking in the street I look
like a homeless person and you still get
people talking to you because there are
just random people that are going to do
that it doesn't matter who you are
that's happened forever do you think
that's a bad thing or or a good thing I
don't really like it how often do you
talk to guys exactly exactly hold on
look what you just said I don't like in
the street no freaking way I'm going
somewhere if they don't Sho your shot in
the street hold on hold on hit me out me
out leave me alone they don't shoot your
shot you never will no yeah but in the
street what if he thinks future wife and
what he shouldn't in the street then he
then we'll meet in a place that is
like sing I can't relate I can't relate
it could be tesos it could be anyway
like okay okay Tesco could be kind
of I got a question last time when's the
last time you when's the last time you
asked the guy out oh well no that's not
I no no right so you basically saying
guys don't interact with me cuz I don't
ask you out so don't interact with me
when I'm walking in the street and I
look like a homeless person let me be
what can I can I can I wait guys guys
can I I just want to point I want to
point something out here I want to point
now don't take this person women will
always
whine imagine imagine imagine someone
comes up to you and says you're
beautiful you want to go out now most
people would just take it as a
compliment you know I might not be
interested but I mean hey that's a
that's a nice thing women we just always
have this tendency to complain you know
somay someday you're you're still cute
you know what I mean not that
[Laughter]
hot but you know you're you're pretty
you're pretty woman right one day you're
going to be old and ugly and you we'll
we'll miss the we'll miss the guys no I
know seriously you know and over 45 it's
like half of us get on anti-depressants
we're going to be all
alone you know okay but I hope for you
you know I'm just saying statistically
right and then it's like um you know I
think they that we'll miss the attention
on some level I really do I do you'll be
like and I've heard Amy Schumer joke
about this where she's like yeah when I
was younger I was like oh I can't
believe they're approaching me and now
I'm older I'm like
please I that's a certain mentality
that's a certain type of person but I
think it's all depends where you are so
like if you're I don't know in a more
sociable area fine I wouldn't shoot
someone down if I was say at a bar or at
a cafe or something but if I'm walking
and I and I well he's he's like there's
less competitors let me go now but you
see you see but this is this is why men
don't approach anymore wild because it's
like it's like confusing for men to like
how are they supposed to know when to
not when they get a bit scared this is
like like guys are like forget it this
is too much I think it's just
ungratefulness that's what it comes down
to I literally feel like yeah because
I'm going tell you why hold I'm tell I'm
going tell you why because you guys
haven't put yourselves out there we had
to get numb to rejection we had to
constantly get rejected and get numb to
it you guys can't take rection as a as a
I've been a model most of my life oh
sorry interesting being interested in
somebody and being a model rection is
part of the
jobet same thing you build a thick skin
and you just no it's not you've never
walked up to hold on you just to clarify
you just said that you don't walk up to
strangers and say hey you're beautiful I
want to talk to you so you would never
be able to look at somebody their face
and say what you know how in front of
everybody imagine being on the street
you some girl says don't touch me leave
me loud and you trying to talk whoa whoa
whoa someone's trying to touch you in
the street that's a red flag but not
even but but but not even just to
attempt to get to know you you
automatically say don't you know like I
said it just comes down to
ungratefulness it's
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait okay okay creepy right what if
what wait wait wait please wait please
wait guys um so so it's creepy but what
if what if he looks who's who's your
celebrity crush I don't really have a
celebrity please please give me an
answer please a real answer let's not do
the woman thing come on no honestly
um okay I'll say Matt r as as a comedian
okay
so okay find him but you find him
attractive he's attractive okay so if he
comes up to you you still find it creepy
maybe it depends no you wouldn't like
don't do the woman thing don't lie like
we're not Liars here okay if he's hot
maybe I'll give him exra see but do do
you see how confusing this is to be but
he has to be really freaking hot
otherwise I'm just I'm not cuz honestly
I want to go where I'm going and I'm if
I'm looking like this I don't how does
he know that he's hot for you how does
he know doesn't well how does he know
what you think is looking like this cuz
men just kind of find women H you know
they're
like they don't even see like that's
like like fashion like men don't even
see it well I've I've got some input
I've got some input on this because
because I do I do dating coaching and we
get we actually get guys to you know to
approach women in real life and I I
personally think that's a good thing
because I think what is [__] about
this Society is that we're all on our
phones we're choosing potential partners
by swiping on a [__] F which seems to
me to be really [__] weird but I
would agree if somebody's like super
busy and they're obviously in a rush or
whatever yeah it's it's bad for them to
to approach them but I I still don't
think even in 2023 even in the west even
in W London I still don't think it's a
bad thing if you think somebody's nice
to walk up and say Hey listen I just saw
you I thought you look really nice I
wanted to come over and say hello now if
she's not interested she says no sorry
I've got a boyfriend I'm not interested
whatever absolutely fine have a great
day see you later if she is interested
or at least there's a glimmer of you
know kind of reciprocation there carry
on the conversation I don't think that's
a bad thing and I think it's bad I think
fortunate in this society that it's
becoming prescribed behavior and when
you travel outside the West you go to
Latin America or even parts of Eastern
Europe actually it's a lot more
acceptable it's only in these countries
like America and here because now
because now you're giving your dating
selection up to these apps no your whole
if no guy if no guy walks up to you in
real life and interacts with you your
whole dating experience will be under
the control of majority of these apps so
depending on that algorithm determines
what type of guy you get and then you're
going to have to compete with all women
from all age groups yeah I just think
it's a shame if people can't talk to
each other anymore I just think I think
there's a time and a place is all I'm
saying and I think when you're walking
and you're in a rush and you definitely
look like you're not just hanging about
waiting to have a conversation with a
stranger that's not the time I think I
think women just like don't know what
they want and I think a lot of women
don't no I think I think this sounds
like craziness she's speaking Laur I've
known Laura for like years and yeah
that's a thing not on the street but
we're actually quite social so we're
always at events and different parties
and all that and that's
when people and I will interact I'm not
an I'm not an animal I just think it's
like crazy to expect the men know when
you want or don't want to be if you're
walking down the street I just think if
you're W like if you're all right what
if you're in Starbucks what if you're in
Starbucks you're in the queue and then
there's a guy behind you in the queue
and he starts talking to you would that
be okay I mean yeah that's
happened okay it's okay CU you have
can I point something out can I point
something I think the the the disconnect
here is the fact that what you feel is
perfectly okay like it's okay to have
that as as in like you don't like it
when people approach you in the street
but the problem is when you look at it
as when a man approaches you then you
have this Vis reaction because like
we're saying men don't know if that's
your preference or that's what the other
girl preference is we just know that
some girls like it some girls don't so
if we're going to be scared and say we
don't know if she's going to like it
then we're not going to approach anyone
all but that's what I do I've said it
before and I've said to men men stop
approaching women stop it 2023 stop it
stop approaching women do not go up to
them when you go outside do not
entertain them a woman see women can let
you know if they're interested in you I
don't believe in that one when a woman's
walking past you should just try to grab
first of all never touch a woman that's
not your woman don't even touch her
first of all yeah when're 2023 this how
you catch a case right no like like like
what is my advice going to be to men and
young men especially at work I've said
before do not not speak to no women at
work cuz what Pearl proved is what one
man is creepy but another man actually
is not so creepy right it becomes a CR
no but but so if a guy moves you at work
and you don't like him it becomes oh
work workplace misconduct but if you
find him cute you're not complaining but
so but how does a man know so it's Bas a
man's not going to know that till he
goes through so my thing is to men is
men stop we need to like so it's I keep
saying it's 2023 right and the reason I
keep saying is because it's very
dangerous for us men are single men we
need to protect ourself at all times you
keep seeing you saw what's with the
Russell BR scenario as well like men
women need to outline it and make it
intentions very very very clear to you
so women can a woman can look at you she
can smile at you she can drop something
she can there subtle things that you
language for indication eye contact but
a lot of guys don't know those things
but you they do okay so you lean in a
little bit and I come and I come the
rest of the way but a lot of guys don't
know those hold on that's only comes but
that only comes for experience men I
want to I want to bring up the other
tweets that I had see I want to see if
you guys I had some more so I wanted
good I want you thought well look it
here's the thing I never say an
individual person if the shoe fits
that's not my fault it is not my fault I
do not make you be alive so I said all
these Fitness chicks are cop because I
would see all these women that were like
in shape and they'll tweet me their
bodies I'm like thank you for
that all these Fitness chicks are coping
that they're still as hot at 35 no
ladies you can't be that hot at 35 22
year-olds will out compete you don't
shoot the messenger and I had some more
um you know then they'll say pearl this
is out of hand then I said then I said
the delusion is so sad that you guys
think you're still as hot at
35 no not really sorry to break the news
now did I say ugly no did I say
unattractive no no but I mean I I think
that this is and I'll tell you how I had
this thought I thought about the most
beautiful 35-year-old women that I knew
and I thought I could find a hotter
chick on any college
campus it just wouldn't be that hard
like but you could also find a lot of
really ugly chicks on College it's true
it's true but unfortunately
unfortunately the the harsh the harsh
reality is that is that men are in part
attracted to to Youth and fertility
that's that's you know and if you look
at there's that famous uh chart isn't
there I think it was taken from OK Cupid
where it looks at Men's ages as they get
older and who they're attracted to and
it's it's around the 23 year old Mark
you know and men are getting into like
30 40 50 60 and they're still attracted
to 23 old with women it shifts slightly
the other way as they get older they're
attracted to SL somewhat older guys so
you know and and and I'm not saying it's
right I'm not saying it's good but it's
a bi it's a biological factor we can't
really escape from and you can't you
cannot compete I'm sorry at 35 you will
not out compete a 22y old you could get
a mid 22y old and she's theoretically
hotter oh she's absolutely hotter and
and men are practical if they want
marriage and children what the 3 so so
Paul the difference between men and
women is is like so for men it would be
it would be Fitness and physicality so
so an older man would understand that a
younger man would have better
physicality in Fitness than him if was
football or something like that right
and they wouldn't try to really bully
yes you will get some men that older
that they keep theel in shape and
they're going to have a better
metabolism yes I get it but the general
rule will be the younger men will be
fitter and will be stronger right um and
we get that we understand that that's
fine but why is it so hard for women to
understand that if you're 35 that a 21
even an average one is probably going to
have a tighter bum than you probably
going to have more subtle breast in you
Firma figure and it's okay because guess
what guess what they still Beauty as you
get older like this thing where and when
we're talking about aging gracefully
you're about to enter a whole different
life why are you trying to compete with
people in your 2122 and us men we don't
try to compete with younger men we don't
we we actually see oursel in younger men
whereas women tend to hate on younger
women you know mean because they see the
women that they used to be you know why
because their trophy is their visual
look women walk around and them looking
this way and having is is their trophy
for men it's more about for men is more
about how much money we got how much
properties we own how much assets we
have but for women is more about the way
I look how beautiful I am how many men
want me well it used to be a family T
tall now oh yeah that thing that thing
that thing forgot about that thing
actually I had I want to actually I want
I want to actually point out um this
other chick I'm gonna I'm going to send
this to you King now I think there's
very few women that live in reality I
wanted to point out something that you
said and I want to point this out you
have a gut reaction women in general we
just have a gut reaction to cope yes
that's what I call cope where I said
where I said um and I wish I wish we
were G have to pull it back so I
remember um where you I said oh but the
22y olds are going to out compete you
and you said but yeah and then you said
something about them being uglier fatter
as in you said the one hot 22 in the
campus yes but there's a a whole load of
others that are not hot but I but in all
honesty I don't compete with 22 year
olds um I just do my own thing I don't
care well see you don't know you are
well don't I'll tell you I'll tell you
so I'll let me let me let me explain you
as a you as a woman you only find % of
men is attractive if you told me the
last guy you dated whatever showed me
his picture guarantee he's in the top
20% of men I've never had any woman
prove me wrong on this okay I've never
never never never he's probably top 20%
of height income something so knowing
that you are competing with 22 year olds
we just don't know it because half of
those men got hella [__] you know
what I'm
say so so you know and and but the
problem is that's another thing um why
do I want a guy that's going to be with
hella [__] I want one
man good so so I'll answer this question
because you pick them now I know you
might say I'm different and I'm an
exception but I don't believe you I
think you I think if you showed me you
could show me the last guy you you dated
whatever you know he would likely be in
the top 20% of men and that's the thing
women don't know the reality of the
people they're dating so we we we think
we're the the only one and we're special
and we're not competing but it's a
competition baby all's fair and Love and
War tall you know you know what tall
short big small it it really doesn't
matter I found that when it comes to
women only one thing really
matters and it's the the size of your
schlong I'm screed I'm screwed I'm
screwed or a small one yeah that's good
pause yeah exactly I just have to just
you know throw that in there pause okay
New
York must to hit
London can can you pull up can you pull
up the next tweet that no not that one
the next one I sent you on Instagram be
views right now I
know she look good
though stop simping like this is it's
not simping she keep it
real keep it real you don't want me to
say you don't want me to say what I was
going to say don't AO you underneath the
bus my guy all right cool I thought to
say all right cool I'll let you don't
set me up don't set me up don't set me
up set she looks okay she looks okay in
that short but it's
probably no I sent you another one king
just now just now it's the last
one but yeah and these women and so then
it's like they'll they'll it's really
weird women have this thing where they
start to like psychoanalyze me you know
that's why I did my therapy video you
know but I feel like you going to come
up way more messed up after that therapy
session oh I know I know I know that's a
therapy sessions usually doe to
women I mean when I saw that you come
through the door I was like no not did
you tell me he was doing that I just
started laughing I was just like okay
yeah so I had um this this chick on
Twitter she seems like the only one that
lives in reality you guys should follow
her because everyone she's a woman in
her 30s she's in her 30s this woman and
um she doesn't cry when I say that the
30 year olds are less hot than the 20s
something year I love her I'm a fan and
so she tweets men are most attractive at
30 than at 80 now tell me why don't I
have male
selfies now where are the men
arguing and saying you know that mine
got millions of views this only got
8,000 where where was the wh why is it
that men can accept like I I would say
men may be PE around I don't know 45 35
depending on the cuz the 80y olds don't
have the internet that's
[Laughter]
true or or if I said you know women
prefer rich men to poor men do you think
they'd tweet me their bank
account n the men the men just EXC they
do they say well I know this one poor
man well po Paul to be fair I mean I
think at is like is is pushing it a bit
but I mean certainly I I have seen
debate on Twitter recently about like
this this whole older guy thing because
a lot of women and some some sort of
simpy guys are pushing back on the idea
that men you know get better with age oh
they they get better with age that well
there's there's a lot of women uh women
who are trying to sort of redress the
balance of the wall and saying like oh
it's it's complete BS to say that women
get better in their 30s and 40s what age
do you think men peek at 47 I'll I'll be
honest okay so okay so I've said said
this last time like and I think there
seem to be something that as you get
older it gets worse but CU I think we
had an image of what older men looked
like when we was younger and I'll be
honest with you like if you looked at
your teacher if you looked at certain
people that overweight they didn't have
a good life but this when I look at you
know some of the men the men of the
world today in their 50s 60s and how
they live and what they've done they
look crazy they look crazy they really
enjoying right and me as a man that's
going to be my 40s in the next decade
right everyone say oh you look so young
you got a young spirit is because the
world hasn't crushed me bro yeah like I
think I think it's very I think it's
very dependent on the guy to be honest I
think I think a lot of men become
crushed by the it's like if the world
hasn't crushed you if you haven't felt
that like I don't have any kids I
haven't had like no woman take me to
court taking my kids no baby mama drama
like I enjoy the things that I do in my
personal life I'm not struggling like
you're not going to feel but a lot of
men by the time they get to this they
have been beaten up they're B my life
it's crazy because cuz when you said
when you said that you was like 39 you
know me as 30 I looked at you was like
he looks great I'm going to look great
at you know so so question what on
average what age do you think men peek
at well I I think I think 30s and
definitely late 30s I think are really
good I mean late 30s for me were really
really good I have to say better than my
better than my 20s a lot
better I think I enjoyed J but it's only
now I'm getting my gears K like I'm
start I'm really enjoying now so I don't
even so I'm kind of confused and all the
things that I want to do and plan to do
is going to come with time so it's only
going to get better right that's what I
think oh how old is Andrew Tate okay 36
okay so I have a question just raise I'm
just curious raise your hands who thinks
men peak at 25 definitely not who thinks
men peak at 30 I think it can begin
raise it please raise hands okay let's
who thinks men peak at
35 30 35 okay who thinks men peak at
40 who thinks men peak at 45
I bet who who thinks PE get 50 I still
think that too
yeah Okay so we've gotten like 47 49 I
mean I I didn't I didn't I didn't meet
my wife until my late 30s and uh I'm 43
and to to you know his point earlier I'm
I'm pretty happily married I Pearl and I
were having this discussion earlier that
you know I actually don't feel bitter
bitter towards women because I have a
woman a wife that respects me she
admires me she's not be me she's not
hitting on me she doesn't have guy
friends she goes meets for drinks she
does good she's not well she's not high
maintenance she's a great mother she's a
great mother so there are a portion of
men who were able to get a lot of women
they were ladies men they were great
with getting women and they're actually
able to get a wife that respects them
and loves them and honestly for I would
say that as art the second oldest guy in
the room I really do think that marriage
and starting a family is the happiest
way in existence for for a man than
being with a bunch of women and then be
loyal to your wife and have her be loyal
to you if find a good woman yeah and
that's the closest you'll be to God how
how long have you guys been married for
I've been I've only had one woman since
my late 30s okay nice have you ever
cheated you know I
wasn't no no I mean I mean how many
times have you cheated sorry no because
no no because because no because
honestly like all jokes aside I don't
like to joke around about you know three
things one is uh homosexuality the other
about pedophilia and the other is about
adultery so once I got once I you look
here this is my my finger if you can see
it I can see it once I got that ring on
I I I play around and I have a daughter
so you know I I don't want my daughter
to grow up without a father okay good
did you that's adultery in in mainstream
Society in our Cinema in the United
States we've normalized adultery that's
a top 10 commandment as a man of faith
I'm against that I have a very strong
view on that when you when you met her
how did you know that she was the one
how did you know right this is this is
this is it for now for life you know
when I met her I was doing private
Equity deals and despite having a you
know pretty good income she didn't know
that I was successful I met her at an
Airbnb I was staying like a hippie in a
tiny room in in on a Spanish Island and
the the host said to me there's two
German girls in the other room and when
I got on the balcony I saw the way her
eyes lit up when she saw me I honestly
feel like as a man the one of the best
things you can do is not show flash if
you can't if you can't get a woman
driving a regular car if you can't get a
woman without showing like who whatever
is the best woman you can get without
showing off anything just off you yeah
that is that is the real you that is a
woman that really really loves you for
who you are and to your point when you
said earlier is she with you on a day
that's bad my wife was with me when I
got sick once or for example one day I
was was bleeding and I couldn't stand on
my feet my wife held me my wife held me
you know what I'm saying and that meant
the world to you to this day you still
would never forget that moment I'll
never forget that moment yeah yeah
exactly and to your point you know you
you're you're very mature to understand
that in your 20s I um it's because I've
been around I've literally been in the
clubs I've been around I've had I've had
fun across the world and then eventually
men get to this point where it's always
cold like it's just cold you can be
around as many girls as you want
but until you find the right woman that
can actually huh I think emptiness
emptiness it's a it's a empty lonely
road for men you know why bro because
there seems to be something like I said
this before um like for men women tend
to think that being single for men is
lit like it can be lit it can be lit let
me not let me not
lie wait let me let me not cap it can be
lit but everything gets boring after a
while right and everything becomes empty
and especially with age like you start
understanding the I want to start
sounding like all these Spirits sex is
energy and a transfer of energy really I
agree with you I agree you and I really
don't want to be transferring my energy
with someone that I just don't want you
know what I mean that's very that's a
very good point and that's one of the
that's one of the problems with if
you're leading a lifestyle that's a bit
more promiscuous because what you're
actually doing is is you're bringing a
lot of different energies into your life
and some of those energies are not
necessarily very good yeah so
essentially right so when you so people
forget so when you sleep around right
cool you sleep around people you got
remember whatever you're sleeping around
with you become and so if she's trash
girl then technically if you allow her
access to you then you become trash and
I know sometimes men don't want to think
like that but I think try what are you
what are you thinking no no sleep around
no no no no because she your 30 no cuz
she might sleep with some guy that's my
op and he's got bad energy now I come
and lay down with her and now his energy
is transferring to me and now I got bad
luck in my life like there certain times
you link certain girls and all of a
sudden once you your whole life is going
to be ruined now I believe those because
those are demon girl demon time bro
you're 100% on point cuz I got to this
point where I like I literally I my
mentality changed my mentality changed
as a guy I just stopped interacting with
like if I see a whole bunch of guys
talking to one girl and she comes over
to talk to me I'm just like nah you go
talk to those guys and engage with those
guys I like but what if she's not
interested in those guys she interested
in you that's like Troy I I'm interested
in what you your face was just kind of
funny when he was talking about the
energy so what were no I kind of
I I kind of agree I kind of agree with
him on the energy look here's the thing
right I think there's there's two sides
to this right I think on the one hand
you know your story beautiful story and
I'm I'm glad you know I'm really happy
for you man because that sounds [__]
brilliant and that's the kind of woman
that's the kind of woman that I think we
would all we would all like to meet I I
do think though it's not necessarily
easy in this day and age to meet a woman
of that caliber and the other the other
issue that I've got is that I yeah
sleeping around kind of gets old on the
one hand but in another way it kind of
doesn't do you know what I mean and I
think guys are always going to have that
and it's great you know you can make you
can make that vow you can make that
commitment to yourself and to your wife
that you're not going to you're going to
be monogamous and that's absolutely fine
people can absolutely make that choice
but for me I think that would be
difficult because I you know that moment
be honest be honest be honest you know
that moment wait guys let him let him
finish for because that will be going
against you know my fundamental male
male no not beliefs my fundamental male
Drive which is B basically variety I
think we all want security and we all
want variety at the same time and that's
the [__] I I can be honest with you
yeah like listen at this point where I
can have as much variety as I want I can
do whatever I want I can have variety
every single day I want and live my best
life but the whole point of when you
have all this variety and naturual fact
you don't want can I can I can I just
can I just wait wait wait but it's like
you've only you're 39 you're not married
so you've never even really tried
monogamy what you mean like what what's
real true monogamy well how long is it
it well I me oh my God so so so I mean
if we think about true monogamy is one
partner for a lifetime yeah but it's
like people are monogamous for like two
years and then they are like oh that's
not my fault I'm not I know I I I'm not
saying like but I'm saying like it's
interesting because people push monogamy
but I really like what is true mon have
you really done it like seven years
eight years like no no really cuz a true
marriage is like 50 years if like
typically right we live to be
so it's like you know it's it's
interesting cuz I have a hard time
believing that if you were 10 20 30
years in you would have zero drive to do
anything okay okay okay you're talking
about 10 20 30 years in yeah okay I'm
not going to talk about that I'm want to
talk about right now yeah no because I
cuz she's saying I don't know okay we we
can't look into the future I would say
that's the that's the path I want to go
along P not so convinced cool what's the
what's I'm not convinced the monogamous
no no no I'm not I'm not saying you
don't mean it
I I think I think I'm just I'm a bit
more of like a realist right so wait
wait wait please
don't just I'm just no no I'm saying I
think sometimes men sell
dreams wait wait wait wait wait let me
let me finish let me finish and I think
men will always have the drive to Cheat
yeah that is true true wait please don't
please stop okay so so and I'm saying
that I think that in a 20 30 40 year
marriage you would have that drive not
every man acts on it but like this idea
that like you you you're just going to
only want monogamy for a lifetime really
because can I just say something can I
just say something I've been trying to
get this point off for a minute now I've
been trying to get this point you talked
a lot I agree with you can can I can I
make one point you see you're saying at
the moment you're saying yeah it gets
old it gets you know and the bad
energies and blah blah blah and that's
fine but like Paul say what if you're
what if you're 20 years in with some
some the sex is like like you're living
in the lap of luxury at the I think let
me just say one thing I think two things
I think the two things could be true at
the same time I think I think monogamy
um is a desirable thing I get why people
want it I get why people want that
security but I also think that you can't
just wish your way around the desire for
for [__] variety desire honest be
honest right now be honest you know that
moment that body goes through when they
all when they're single for a long time
and you get home from after hooking up
with a girl whatever yeah and it's just
quiet in your house yeah and you just
feel that emptiness yeah empty you you
know what I'm talking we've all been at
that position where you're sitting there
you have all these girls in your phone
but as soon as you get home the house is
just empty can I can I actually can I
that's that's like every Sunday for me I
mean also i' also like to point out that
there's no guarantee that you wouldn't
feel lonely in a marriage I know many
men interview men all the time that felt
extremely lonely in a marriage so this
idea that like you get married and like
all of the sudden you'll never feel
lonely again if you're lucky yeah but
that's why but that's the reason I tell
people all the time don't don't Focus so
much on the love of your marriage build
something outside of your marriage so
you have one two most people just get in
love and have relationships they get it
together and then the love is what keeps
them together I I just think here at
this stage right I at this stage you're
looking to settle down no I would no I
yeah I would look to settle down but I
just I'm not chasing
it can I just say women always want men
that are experience so how do you think
they're going to get the experience
unless they [__] it
about part of their women will complain
to be like oh they don't know how to
have sex properly they kid they have to
go out and actually experiencing it
crack on until your 30 when you he 30
you just get your sh but the point can I
can I just say the point the point that
these guys are making about the sort of
The Emptiness the lon
the existential Gloom of the The
Bachelor you know Playboy lifestyle is
absolutely true but that doesn't mean
that monogam is [__] brilliant either
so in the end do you have to choose your
own poison no no I think listen to this
to be I'll be I'll be honest with you
negative I mean I think there's there's
winners and losers in life I think
there's some Bachelor contend I mean
yeah I mean I think there's some
Bachelors that I don't think we should
be I think there's some family men that
have it amazing like it just but I don't
think we should be I don't know like I I
don't think we should be shooting it
down cuz you don't you don't you you
don't sound like you got faith in me
like PE
like okay China China China I'll tell
you I'll tell you what what I don't have
faith what I do have tell me go let me
hear I I think in general most men like
yourself would like to settle down and
have a family yeah I think in general
the men that want to and find the right
girl will do it okay um whether you know
I think that's increasingly tougher in
today's market I think there's going to
be a lot of guys that don't find a girl
that's worth the risk in in all honesty
but I think it's selling a dream to say
that men will be happy monogamous for a
lifetime I typically find that the men
that say that have not been married long
enough for me to really consider it
monogamy it's one thing to say it in
your 30s and your 40s but 50s 60s 7s you
know life life is long so you know true
monogamy I think we've almost lost what
true monogamy is because how many people
have been with one partner
and then you get to 60 and then your
wife decides to leave cuz she hasn't
lived it full
life reget this this is this is not to
hate on anybody this is not like I
genuine I love I love it when like I get
stories all the time of people sending
me like their oh I'm so happy I used to
work and I did like I watched your show
I stopped working I stayed home or like
I did you know I get these stories all
the time and it's like it warms my heart
a little bit especially especially when
I like find out there's like women that
you know think kind of the same way get
a little you know but but it doesn't
what I know I will in a second but it
doesn't you know discount reality yeah
the reality I feel like every time I
come here a little bit of my marriage
dream gets crushed I'll tell you I'll
tell you what I believe will be the
future and this isn't I don't say this
in a happy way but I think we're going
to see birth rates similar to Japan
Japan is at 0.52 that's their birth rate
W it's gone down yeah yeah um I you know
um there's different reasons the women
yeah I think we're going to see the
people that are sexist go up is that a
government thing though well yeah I mean
there's a lot of I don't I don't really
know I don't know Japan's like culture
economy like that I just if I had to
guess South Korea is similar I I think
the trends seem to start there and then
they come here you got big incel culture
though as well haven't you in Japan so I
think maybe something I think that's
going to I think that's going to
increase too I think there's going to be
more incels here I mean the quality of
life is going downhill anyway so
I think you're going to I think men just
naturally weigh the risks and the
rewards and I think right now the women
are less rewarding than ever and the
risks are higher than ever some guys
will find their unicorn and I think
that's beautiful but I'm not in the
business of sell honest my worst
nightmare like I've said it before in it
and i' I don't know if I said on this
platform but like my worst nightmare is
being being a baby daddy on a weekend
dad and the reason why I said it um is
because first of all I need my weekends
I got stuff to
do I get busy but and nothing more
expensive than paying for a child
outside of basically you're financing
two homes but more importantly he like
what can I do within that day and a half
there's nothing I can do right and
because of that and because I'm
passionate you guys I'm a very
passionate person and I know what girls
can do to me like no girl can do
anything unless you have leverage over
me so I can walk away the moment you
have my child I have to call you back
yeah I have to every single time I have
to call well some men don't you're right
and that's that's the issue is even if
you don't get married you still are
entered into this system where where the
women automatically have leverage and
when women get leverage for some reason
we do the wrong thing true now I'm not
I'm not saying that there aren't women
that are awesome and special but I just
think if I had to predict 10 years in
the future I don't say that I'm I'm not
in the business of selling dreams I'm
not a Steve Harvey type of chick you
know what I mean I I just think I would
predict that marriages will go down I
would predict there's going to be less
children in families and I would predict
that half of the women will be single a
quarter divorced in a
quarter married and out of the married
ones it's like kind of half and half
with happiness you know so I'm I'm just
you know I'm not happy about this but
you know until I see I would really love
to see Elon Musk I see him pushing for
families and I would really love to see
him pushing for Family Court reform
because I think that's when you'll start
to see men saying okay you know yeah she
did only fans but now she can't steal my
children you know you know and it'll
start not only I'm just only fans is a
joke but you know but but you guys get
the idea like yeah okay the women they
have problems but we can work with them
she can't leave me and take my [__] yeah
although I think was it even Matt Walsh
I mean the one thing that Matt Walsh was
probably right about um when he was on
he did his little segment about you
recently on his show P was that the
family court reform is going to take so
long you know it would take a long time
wouldn't it to change those laws and so
then it's the question of what did the
dudes do now you know yeah and the issue
well and it's not it's not really
necessarily what I tell people to do I'm
just saying this is going if we if the
laws do not change this will happen like
there is no there I don't see any
evidence to suggest otherwise yeah but
it's very interesting to see a guy like
China who's from a completely different
culture to me completely different side
of the world and we have similar values
about I don't want to be a Deb be D I
don't want to be the baby daddy that's
can I tell you something you said to me
come from a single pardon me from a
single um Mother home right and it's so
you have the the men that are raised
from a single mother you said you saw a
struggle right you saw those things
right yeah and it's funny that you would
think that most men that would see that
their mother struggling would go out to
become the best version of thems and you
know to be the man that their dad wasn't
around but they tend to go and recreate
the exact same thing they come from so
but then you get the other hand men like
you that won't get that but they will
see their mom's struggle they're
actually going to be like right I want
to become married and they haven't seen
it and I it's weird because I have
friends on the other side and I have
friends on the other side on the other
side and and when I just hear it it just
makes me think that why is it that men
want that why is it that you why do you
feel that something that you need to
provide is that something is it because
you didn't have it is it because you saw
your mom struggle I would never want any
child to feel the way I felt when I was
younger what sorry what was that it was
uh basically my father called me he
called me one time on my birthday said
what you want what you want for your
birthday but that time 50 Cent was
popular yeah he's like yo I can buy you
this new 50 Cent game that just came out
and I'm like N I just want to hang out
with you bulletproof yeah you know
I said no will proove is fire finished
it but still got the game but um yeah
and I said you want to make hang out
with you he says okay I'll come I'm come
pick you up we get some ice cream okay
I'll be sitting downstairs waiting hour
pass still waiting my mother come
downstairs hey you want to go get some
ice cream and go do these different type
of things so it's people handle it
differently you know but everyone goes
through trauma every single person has
some kind of form of Trauma from their
childhood everyone goes through trauma
but as a guy you adapt from it you use
it as a strength yeah but as a guy like
for me to see that and you know me and
my brother went through the same thing
our mentalities are completely different
but to see that and to see how hard she
worked to see how she she had us like 15
16 years old is that why you want a
strong woman because you saw your mom
being a strong woman so you want a
strong woman to build I knew I knew if
she had somebody as diligent as her next
to her it would it would it would have
been yeah it would have been even more
epic you know what but you know it's
possible that because she was a strong
woman that's why she didn't have a
stable relationship [__] I think that
she was just tooo young too immature at
the time it's and this is just like from
interviewing like hundreds of PE cuz I I
find that I kind of that is true that is
true I kind of want I kind of find like
when I find men that like and this isn't
like a personal thing but like but it's
like when I I I find that guys that want
the strong women tend to come from
single mother homes not really I don't
want to use the word strong let's use
digilant yeah when they use traits that
tend to describe more masculine it's cuz
they usually had a masculine mom hey hey
you know what Pearl actually you know I
have a theory it's like you know Deion
Sanders I think his father wasn't there
his uncle wasn't really there and he's
just this amazing father he's an amazing
family man so you know with me I grew up
with a single mother who was very strong
and you know and marriage well yeah my
my my my my wife gives me something I
never had and my mom was very loving to
me it almost seemed like it might have
been a chore for my mom to love me man
she she didn't have that warm warm love
towards me so you know what I did on you
know what I did I picked a wife that by
disposition is very warm cuddly friendly
yeah patient just the nicest sweetest
woman I've one of the nicest sweetest
women i' ever met and you know what you
know what she does for my daughter
she'll wake up at 3 5 6 it doesn't
matter she is an outstanding mother and
extremely warm to my daughter and I just
want to say something to you man I can
buy a lot of things as a high net worth
individual but I can't buy a warm loving
mother from my daughter and that's the
one thing I can't buy so that's what I
got from my daughter it's crazy that you
say that because that's literally the
one thing my mother said to me when she
when when I started growing up she said
I wish I hugged you more you know she
said she literally looked at me like I
wish I hugged you more my mom never said
that to me but she probably got that
from her mother it's normally
generational she said that you know and
and I was just like yeah but I but I I
got the point how old's your mom young
like I don't know she about to be 50 49
48 around that age that's the that's
like the age that's what I call like the
age of shitty wies to be honest it's
like 40 to 60 because it's like they
either like [__] up they either got
divorced had a kid out of wed like they
she was married my mother was married
she had she just had us at a very young
age she got married she she got divorced
though right no she's actually she's
still married oh oh I oh I totally
thought you said divorce no they just
not together but she's still
married but they're not they're not okay
so why' you was the point okay okay so
they're not together okay so but like
the technicality all right so 40 40 to
60 like it's the the generation I call
like shitty wives because the 60 to 80
year olds told their daughters to always
have a backup plan go to work 40 to 60
they tended to that they were the ones
that got divorced they were the ones
that um had the careers and like were
kind of the more masculine ones cuz they
had the wrong information from their
moms that's just kind of what I I have a
question what what is this obsession
with the Western World and this
uh we need we need hugs and cuddles and
and and all these unfed love from our
par King the
Niger like life is tough your parents go
through a lot to provide for you to make
sure you don't die to make sure you
literally survive and then people grow
up and they complaining oh my mom didn't
hug me like what the hell is that n King
you know what
I think African and and Middle Eastern
culture do have some similarities
especially in particular because of
Islam so as a middle eastern man my
father was Irani and my mother's Jewish
but my my father built the toughness in
me and I think that a lot of Middle
Eastern fathers have that in common with
African fathers and I say that
respectfully and one last thing I live
in a German Village basically a German
City and in the German City that I live
almost the little village that we are so
many people are happily married married
and so many people live long lives it's
a simple lifestyle when you come to
these big cities you see this
ratchetness this this this this Gutter
and respon to King as a Wester coming
but wait it's coming as a it's wait it's
coming the it doesn't really matter all
the I get messages from people in the
country and some some places I would say
are 20 years behind but if you look at
birth rates promiscuity rates it's all
spreading could I just say rates could I
just say something sorry to be Doom and
Gloom enjoy theine can I can I just say
something back to back to King so king
king's bringing some like Alpha
masculinity into into the dialogue here
because if actually if you go back
Generations if you go back to my
grandparents generation and then and
then my great grandparents generation
also actually the parental role
particularly the father you know the
father was often kind of absent the
father was out doing his stuff you know
going and doing his business he wasn't
fathers were often these very remote
distant figures and motherly love you
know sometimes it would depend on the
woman but I is it a a case that we've
become and I'm not saying it's a bad
thing but are we becoming somewhat
softened you know so we feel this need
for this this great love from our I mean
back in the day kids in Britain you know
in the upper classes you just get set
away to school at the age of they would
even see their [__] parents but I do
believe there there's there's a certain
amount of love that young young men need
young boys need man especially in the
pivotal point when they're dealing with
their masculinity with testosterone in
the teenage years and once again I don't
want to keep talking about that you know
that issue with a girl that got stabbed
rip Lana but you know she was stabed by
17 your boy and we don't know who raised
him and one of the things I do want I
want to ask is who raised him is
because like one of the things I said
when you have a teens that struggling
their masculinity without a a male role
model in the house to teach them how to
deal with it I was quite I I went
through the same thing I didn't
obviously didn't end up on the wrong way
of things but I know people that did and
I was quite fortunate to have my father
in my life but my dad was a diplomat and
he spent half of his life away traveling
so then you still get the same effect
because my mom raised me and when your
mom raises you pick up some of the
traits or reaction quick or whatever
where my dad is actually my dad is very
calm man he's he's never shout at me
he's never raised his hand to me nothing
it CES down to one particular thing is
my mother said you have no empathy for
people you don't feel soft you need a
cat or a dog to take care of people
because especially growing up in these
inner cities you grow up in these inner
cities you start to become very vicious
do you feel do you feel your dad was
very loving even though he was had a had
a he traveled a lot yeah no yeah no yeah
only yes yes that's my guy like the only
thing that one of the things that I
regret not even regret is just that he
made so many we were the first
generation so he made so many sacrifices
because of his job right and it's just
that and I saw what my mom did as well
my mom my mom all my sisters are
business like bosses and they're right
but they're all married right and so was
my mom she bought has did everything but
she always submit to my dad but I just
couldn't do that because out of
everything my dad did all I ever think
is that I wanted more time with him do
you get me but in order for me to be
here and have opportunities he had to
make that sacrifice I just feel like I
just feel like when cuz my dad was going
a lot going up growing up like working
I'm like yeah life goes
on yeah but it's true
because you know it's like ah oh well
yeah but it's true because the one
difference I I noticed is like like in
Africa the reason why a lot of kids um
don't have this same kind of reaction
yeah is because from from when you're
young if you're in the lower class um if
you're if you're born into a lower class
what happen What tends to happen is you
start to work from a very young age mhm
if you're born into a higher class you
get put into a lot of activities so
either ways you're busy as a kid you're
not sitting around waiting for your dad
to come and hug you or your mom to come
and do all of that crap because reality
is the way we show love in Africa is by
providing it's not about feelings is
have you eaten today yes do you have a
roof over your head yes are you are you
sleeping on the street no that's how you
know your parents love you it's not by
them telling you oh come let me give you
a hug and all that it doesn't I don't
love you I mean it'ss that I mean listen
I travel a lot I travel a lot for work
just like your dad and and you know I
bet you your father missed you a lot man
I know I miss my daughter right now I
won't see I haven't seen her about four
or five days I miss her I bet your
father missed you even though he was
traveling you can you can see your you
can get on the phone and you can see me
we have to do the phone card you have to
wait for the line to get no it was you
know it was it was those days right and
I just it's only now Pearl doesn't like
you know po had po you I had brothers
and sisters but it's only now I realize
how limited time I've had with him
that's all I'm saying to you like and
because he lives in African travel still
a lot it's just that I realize the
sacrifices he made and and that's all it
is I just think as you get older you
just start to see when everyone keeps
talking about me me me yeah I look at
what my mom and dad did and I don't
think I what I couldn't be away from my
woman on my woman be away from me just
for our kids and that's all I'm saying
PA that's it so I'm going to I'm going
to read super chats for for a second
guys I haven't gotten to them but your
father did think about you a lot I
guarantee you I know I think about my
daughter um okay so um Doug MPA says who
needs only fans when you can follow
Pearl on
Instagram hey premium premium wow keep
calling out these old birds so they can
keep sending pictures for research
purposes of
course 93 to pie if um women didn't care
what their friends thought of their
boyfriend they would be happier but the
fact remains they have to have their
cake and eat it too a beautiful
35-year-old will never be an ugly
19-year-old Patrice O'Neal it's hard to
explain in text what women like but it's
too simple for men to get um FS Claire
when why we are watching why men
shouldn't get married reality is
questionable when it highlights
something they don't like in no other
instance would we support people signing
a contract rate are a contract with a
failure rate marriage has crypto Smith
men don't divorce once they level up
that's what women do think about it men
don't care about their Partners finances
or ability to provide women care a lot
about that yeah guys that's why I say
men are better people because when they
get yeah you think I'm kidding you think
I'm kidding I know people think I troll
but like I mean you know sometimes I I
might make jokes but usually you can
tell when I say men are better people I
mean it to its entirety and the reason I
mean it is cuz I look at what women have
done when we've gotten power and
leverage and it's usually something
along the lines of ab something along
the lines of abusing men in the court
system in the marriage system um at work
the women will cry and whine that the
men harass them at
work and it's like I just can't stand it
I just drives me freaking nuts the men
are harassed at work they don't complain
they get bullied at work they don't want
women just love to whine and complain
and men when they get money they tend to
provide for a wife and their kids when
women get money they tend to keep it for
themselves divorce their husbands and
you know I'm not saying there aren't
exceptional amazing women there are but
when I look at us as a whole yeah
they're better people I don't know what
to tell you now um and you know and then
I know the one argument I get is well
the men commit the crime and I'm like
well that's like saying a woman that
can't commit a crime like they can't do
the stuff men do but when we look at
infants and the elderly you know who
kills them the most women it's like
crazy Carlos okay um you're letting
yourself get trolled China don't feed
the troll um Doug MP Ching I'm Ching
Nina is a scumbag he says nothing of
substance in his craft for no reason
please don't have him on the show again
easily one of the worst guests had a
police who is it now Ro whose show is it
Road man Doug MPA everyone listen to The
mm's Voice China he's the realest out in
the streets New York black dude would
build an Empire with a woman question
mark um bro is talking like a textbook
simp too many American black men are
simps um percules look up the Articles
women are more likely to delete children
if the woman loses custody men are more
likely to delete themselves yeah guys
guys I I just have to I just have to be
honest like I'm I'm just an honest
person and every time at first I I
didn't actually think like this but I
kept looking at data and numbers no like
God damn ladies this is not good like um
okay Enter black dragon the problem with
modern marriages is the fact that women
expect to be taken care of for the rest
of their lives while men only have a
wife until she finds better options or
time gets hard um Doug MPA um follow
Pearl on Twitter not Instagram sorry
yeah you gave I was like what the hell
stop stop stop speaking on my insta like
I was like my insta's not like like that
okay um there's a difference between a
wife and a woman who is married a wife
represents a family and a husband by
letting people know the world that she
is married actually I have a question do
you think the major do you think the
majority of married women today are
wives wait is that what talking about
like future wives traditional wives you
no no so I I think there's a difference
between someone who's married and a wife
you know Hardy B is married is she a
wife but so you know you know what and
when I think of a wife this is what I
think of personally maybe you guys have
a different thought I think the the
number one thing as a wife that you need
to do it's actually not cooking it's not
wearing a dress it's not cleaning okay I
think it's obeying your husband and
submitting to his authority I know women
that I would consider traditional and
they put the family first too but I
consider them traditional and they don't
know know how to cook they don't know
how to clean at their house they
Outsource everything this is an
exception not most Americans can't live
like this but they they literally
Outsource everything and she works where
her husband tells her to work she does
what her husband tells her to do and
that's it and I would still consider her
traditional because she's still putting
the family first they just have a
different strategy of how to do it right
so that's my question do are the
majority of women married today do they
obey their
husbands and submit to his authority and
put the family first by that definition
absolutely not cuz by the divorce rates
then no I mean we we really should not
scold women for being narcissistic
selfish terrible or
bad they they were born that
way it's not it's not their
[Laughter]
fault I think a lot of women I think I
think a lot of women um certainly that
I've come into contact with in London um
they it's a cliche to say it but they
want the wedding they want the Instagram
wedding you know they like the idea of
it I think they like the actual business
of being married less than they like the
idea of it oh um so it's it's more of a
sort of a box ticking exercise it's like
right I'm 28 right okay I better get a
ring on it and you know do all the stuff
and then five six years later you know
go south they get divorced and that's it
I actually forgot one thing I wanted to
add for the wife and this is how I do
tests right to see like women don't know
I test them all the time now this is not
to
say that it's that that I I am the
epitome right but I am saying I do
little tests to like kind of see where
Women's heads are at and what how does
she respond when you say that she's not
the greatest thing since sliced
bread because women are some wives are
kind of supposed to have humility so
when women are tweeting at me they self
because I say they're not that hot I
think well This Woman's married but it's
kind of weird she's tweeting me her you
know it's a bit Yeah but why you know
what I think a lot of men make the
mistake of even marrying women that are
on social media doing stuff like that
like my wife doesn't do stuff like that
she's not on social media people say to
me oh how do you make these jokes and
what does your wife think well first of
all my wife's German she doesn't really
watch social media but not only that
she's not really on social media like
when you know on your phone you can see
how long you're actually on social media
it's like one hour a week for her a lot
of people are not on social media like
that a lot of you guys can actually
avoid a lot of this by just marrying a
woman who has a good relationship with
her dad and her mom her parents are
still together her grandparents were
together you look at four out of her
five best friends they're in happy
relationships now if I'm going to St
here say oh my relationship my marriage
is perfect I never get angry no I'm a
moody son of a [__] my wife deals with
me too but but does she piss me off
occasionally yeah she might take too
long to make dinner she may make me wait
15 minutes n sometimes she makes me
25 minutes to to go somewhere I get
pretty pissed off if you want to know
the truth but but it's pick your hard
work do you want your hard work to be
your marriage and having a family and
being closer to God what what is natural
for a man is to start a family get
married become a father and the woman's
natural role is to be a loving nurturing
mother why do you want to be involved in
this degeneracy of banging a bunch of
women and
promos and one more thing every woman
you bang every woman you bang you lose a
piece of yourself man told you yeah if
if you if you bang a lot of women you
know if you bang a lot of women man you
start losing a piece of yourself still
practicing though right all how many
women you got SLE with before you
disappear so I have I I have a question
how old's your wife my wife is about 11
years younger than me and just you know
so so she's like 30 something yeah and
you know what like I'm just I'm just
curious my wife's about 11 years Young
younger than me but you want to know
what I know my testosterone is pretty
high cuz I I I just got tested about a
month ago but just so you know I was
immature it took me to my late 30s to
really understand can I be with just
woman and can I want to say one more
thing to you this is the biggest problem
I have with social media the the guys in
their 20s and 30s they're so obsessed
with am I [__] am I [__] am I
getting [__] am I getting [__] let me
tell you when I see my daughter's eyes
and the way she smiles at me and my
heart melts my life is way more
important than me just going and [__]
a woman first of all it's about being
when you see the love you know your
father he's so happy when you're going
to go in a few weeks to see him for his
birthday that's going to be the best
gift when he's in bed with his mom with
your mom and no one's there and he talks
about all the gifts his 10 kids give him
I guarantee he's going to say the number
one gift was my princess to him you're
his princess pearl she came for my
birthday and that's why I said what Happ
you're not a man you're not you're not a
man with a daughter I am you'll never
know what that feels like but I know
your father without even meeting him
he's going to say my princess pearl okay
I don't think he's yeah but
Mar's sorry I I don't think you'd have
to know my D he's going to watch this
now cool you princess when you get hey
princess but um no what was I GNA so how
old your wife's in her 30s though right
31 31 yeah so the thing is with this new
generation they're all on social media
like you can't and the data is going to
indicate this too like the the risk
taking of teens is going down like
there's less with licenses less with
real everything's online I don't say
this in a happy way risk TI King like
like um like like teenagers now are less
less risky than they were in the last
generation and it's because and I I
could see this totally with my little
sisters like my it's funny my youngest
sister she's um 10 years younger than me
and oh my gosh yeah she's like on um her
Discord all the time she's like she's
like a little gamer you know but but
they're all like totally online there's
like nobody so what percentage let me
ask you what percentage of women and men
in marriages do you think are actually
happy um at what
age just in at at 40 50 at
80 um I would say people are generally
so happy in their 30s early 40s I think
something seems to switch in their like
mid 40s to 50s but how how long is it
how long does someone marry before they
get unhappy what's the average then I
mean if we're gonna look stats it's like
seven to eight years before they divorce
I think the woman initiates at like six
so maybe the ages I gave you were a
little seven is that the sevene itch
thing yeah yeah so um I if I had to
guess and the reason I would say this is
I think most men aren't happy with an
overweight wife I I would I would and I
have I've pulled men on this is it a w
if your woman gains 50 pounds um I I
would say out of a hundred marriages
um half will divorce so that that at
least indicates that they were unhappy
out of the half that stay I would say
it's 5050 so I would say if you get
married it's a 25% chance well you talk
you talk about overweight women you know
it's interesting because I dated fashion
models in New York that were very skinny
and I had a hard time actually getting
erection to skinny women but I like
women that are thick and I know on
Twitter somebody said oh simp say they
like thick women knock my father the
most Alpha men one of the most Alpha men
males I know Middle Eastern Iranian man
he said I like this women Middle Eastern
like thick women we value big tits big
thighs you know big you know big ass we
value that as a cultural trait so you
know the idea of what's Beauty to one
man is not necessarily Beauty to another
that's absolutely true I mean I've got
friends I've got friends like if in my
group of friends right there's dudes and
they've got completely different tastes
you would think that there would be one
standard and there really isn't so I to
totally yeah but I think there's a
difference between thick and obese yeah
that's
and there's and there's a lot of women
that just get crazy like and I I think
if you took so out of the 50% that stay
married right I think if you took out
the cheaper to keeper which is a good
percentage of men that are just like I
don't want to I don't want to lose half
my [__] I think there's a good
percentage of men that stay together
because of you know religion right not
saying that's necessarily a bad thing
right but I think like what would you
count as a successful marriage I would
say people that look back and say you
know I'm happy I signed that this was a
good person to spend my life with they
don't we don't argue all the time they
don't make me miserable right I would I
would guess that um half um you get you
get the women that gain weight the ones
that stay together for religion and the
cheaper to Keepers out of the 50% I
would say maybe 25% stay and so what
would you say is the best thing for
based of your stats based off everything
that we just said what do you think is
the best thing for a guy to do in this
modern day age about marriage and kids
and stuff like that she's gonna tell you
not to get married no no so I don't I
don't really I I just think it depends
what your outcome is and what level of
risk you want to take on I think you
know what I mean so like my my thing is
I just don't like men making decisions
without informed consent and most men
have no idea what they are signing up
for when they sign that paper or have
that child true um I I I would like I
think it's going to differ like the
factory worker is going to have a
different answer than say the plumber
but like like you you're successful
you're Progressive you do a lot of
different things you're highly
intelligent you can have multiple
different
conversations how would How would how
would you think a guy should handle a
woman like
you I'm just you're still on the market
right that's a that's a broad that's a
broad how should I be handled I would
say I would say I take you as one of
those type women I take you as one of
those the question I'm like I I think
typically you know the the how do that's
like not a really good question you know
what I mean should he ask you to marry
him on the first date no no no no I mean
that's happened to
me I really want to know I really want
to know can you tell us hold on I really
want to know cuz you're very opinionated
you have a lot of different perspectives
and I want to
know I want to know for woman how am I
handled you
know kind of know I didn't take I didn't
take you as one of those type of women
but okay no I'm not but you know
everyone's going to watch this video for
how to pull up on P now that's what I
know I just I just think that I I just
think you know every guy has to pick for
himself I think there's men like Neema
who go to Germany and find what sounds
like an exceptional awesome chick and
I'd say for guys like that you know
sounds great sign up I think there's
some men that never find a woman that's
worth the
risk I think I think here's what here's
what I think I think it's got to be
completely individual I think you've got
to make an informed decision I think if
you do get married you've got to make
sure that you you know you vet as much
as you can and I'm a little bit
skeptical about vetting because I I
think it's very hard to know how
somebody's going to behave 15 20 years
down the line under pressure but
nevertheless you know you've obviously
got to make sure you're with with the
right the right woman and you've got to
be prepared to to to go the hard yards
with that but I think if that's if
that's not something that you're feeling
in the depths of your soul if if there's
guys who are thinking well I'm not just
not sure if that's really what I want to
do with my life I think that now in 2023
going into 2024 if you want to remain
single and and no I'm just saying if you
want to remain single if you want to
continue dating if you want to have a
different sort of life that is perfectly
possible now I I think I think the whole
R talked about this years ago the whole
lonely old man myth I think is a myth I
don't think it has to be like that it's
not a death sentence so all of these
trads on Twitter who saying to stu oh
you're going to die alone all this sort
of [__] have always died alone so well
and even even I was thinking like if
you're going to sell if you're gonna
some so if someone says what car should
you buy well it depend you would ask
like 10 questions right like do you have
a family do you have like I grew up my
parents had a 16 passenger
[Music]
van you know every guy has a different
situation there's some men that honestly
don't make enough money aren't
good-looking enough that women will
respect them but here here here's the
problem though you're right it's about
an informed decision and the problem
with some of these trads and the Matt
wshes of this world and people like that
is what they're basically saying is just
wife some chick up you know and it's
almost indiscriminate and and they don't
and they'll just no no no no Troy she
has to pray oh
okay
any any sort of objection or any sort of
potential problems that you might bring
up they'll handwave them away and say
yeah that doesn't matter you know just
find a high quality woman and I think
that's problematic for young well yeah
and I think I think it dismisses like
female nature and and the truth of the
matter is remember a 100 years ago 85%
of women were virgins yeah 85 the
average woman was 120 pounds so what
does that tell you about female nature
there's a reason that we we buy the
stupidest fashion trends you'll see us
with these giant h one year then we have
the puff like we well it's cuz women
tend to go with Trends and if being
single is trendy women tend to do it as
as literally the only married man here
uh and and a dad I think that a lot of
you young men have this really dark
image of marriage I and I must be a simp
because I'm married I I spent 10 years
working in New York City nightclubs
[__] a lot of women and you want to
know something nothing brings me
happiness and More close to God than
when my little princess looks at me in
my eyes in the morning in bed next to me
and I also see my wife there you know I
I'm more happier that way and I feel
that all of you young men are better off
being sober not smoking not drinking
praying being married having a family
being loyal to your wife this is the way
of the highest level of fulfillment and
happiness in life that I have found I
would be dishonest and lying and a
fraudulent charlatan to tell you [__]
[__] is the best way for the deepest
sense of happiness and purpose in your
life and that's what I want it's just
not that's what I
want I think your your you're
conflicting the issues and you're kind
of minimizing the the point I get what
you're saying and what you're saying is
true for a man like you yeah but you're
forgetting that the average man which is
the majority is not the man like you the
average man doesn't have access to the
kind of resources you have doesn't have
wouldn't would probably never get access
to the kind of respect that women can
give to you that's a fact so no matter
how hard he works no matter how much he
wants to be married if he gets into a
marriage he's more than likely going to
be faced with disrespect than respect
yeah NE Nema could I could I ask a
question do you think that the fact that
you you've met a woman who is you know
sounds like an outstanding woman do you
think you were helped in that by the
fact that you spend that Playboy period
of time in New York City you know how to
handle women you're obviously a very
articulate intelligent you know
good-looking guy etc etc so you're
ticking a lot of boxes here so if
there's an average guy who's like 22 and
he's reading Matt wolsh tweets and he's
like oh okay I'm just going to wife up
Sheila from the office his outcomes may
not be as favorable as yours yeah I mean
there's something to be said I mean I I
was the last one out of my Social Circle
to get married I mean I I was the most
immature one I loved [__] women I
probably had a sex addiction you know so
so now that I'm with one woman is it
hard for me when I go out I still feel
like young women may look at me and when
I'm at at at the boxing gym yesterday
you know I saw a woman and she was
showing me her fat ass and obviously I
was obviously obvious no but really I
was I was I was turned on but when I
look at my ring you know I realized
what's most important to me and that's
what my grandma before she passed away
my grandma looked at me in my eyes and
she said to me and my wife a few weeks
before she died she said be good to each
other my grandma didn't raise me to
cheat on my wife and be degenerate she
raised me to be a man of faith and be a
good father and a good husband and and
be sober Don't drink don't smoke be a
good man be a man of honor and integrity
and character I would be dishonest if I
said in an awful role model for any
young man if I promoted that sort of
degeneracy this is the problems in our
society many of you don't have loyal
fathers loyal mothers who love each
other and lead by
example what we do have in society is
the [__] economy the world going
completely sou so you have to think
about the external factors because it's
not only do you mean the relationships
we have with one another reality and I
think what you're saying sounds really
nice it does
it wait wait let me let me
finish
let me finish let me finish so but I'm
just not in the business of selling
dreams and and no no I'm not in the
business of crushing them but I I think
a lot of times men are very naive to
family court and and what it's like for
an average man in America and the
average man makes about
$45,000 a year he's 5'8 in overweight
now we can get rid of the overweight
thing but most most men are average
earners and will be average earners for
a lifetime and the truth of the matter
is that none of these podcasters that
are the success Hustlers whatever could
do what we do without the average men
that build this country and
unfortunately average women do not
respect average men how how how strong
would you say and I and I asked this
respectfully and you know I got a lot of
love for you how strong is faith in your
life I'm Catholic but is is faith strong
to you is it is it do you pray on a
daily basis for example I would call
myself a bad
Catholic I would say I would say there's
there's there's there's better Catholics
and there's worse Catholics but I'm just
I honestly don't really like when people
use their faith to win an argument and I
just I know no offense it's just like I
I don't think it's like um I I don't
really like to make it part of like a
brand like it feels like wrong to me no
because I no but you know what is Pearl
uh as a 43y old talking to an educated
26y old woman I think that if more
people prayed on a daily basis and they
married someone that had also had faith
we would avoid a lot of these dis to and
I get this and I get this argum a lot
but the question is what's our standard
for a faithful woman so and and I'm
going to break it down for you so so and
the issue is so I looked at the numbers
because all these tradcons will say oh
just find a good woman just find a good
woman one out of four still divorce of
people that attend attend church that's
not an insignificant number so three out
of four stay together but wait let me
let me let me finish and and we can we
can agree right the women of today are
worse than yesterday so I I don't see
that number getting smaller I see it
getting bigger it just stand so then so
then wait wait so what what is my
standard for a faithful woman wouldn't
you agree it's a virgin because those
women that really take their faith
seriously will wait till they're married
well you only have 4% of women waiting
so you know I'm just not in the business
of selling
dreams but look at but look at the
attitude there let just let's let's look
at the same
and I want all the young me when this
she said one out of still get a div you
can look at it like that but you can
also look at it as three out of four
don't well I and I think and I think
that maybe attitude a lot of this is
your attitude but I think that's maybe
from your point of view because I've
seen I've seen wait wait wait I have
interviewed men on the other side of
this and I don't think you know the
death that goes through a man's eyes
when he knows that he cannot see his
daughter or his son for years how about
have you interviewed happily married men
have you interview wait wait I yes yes I
have I know I know there are happily
married men I'm not I'm not saying that
and and I and the and the thing is like
the tradcons often get triggered by by
these stories or whatever but my point
is they are not uncommon and they are
not rare I agree and so and so there are
women that manipulate like they haven't
seen their kid in years they've lost
half their income any person that has
worked in father's rights father's is
getting custody of their children knows
that those men there are so many men
that commit suicide and this isn't like
if you took a pill and there was a 5%
chance of dying you would never take it
we hear about these coid shots right
everybody's going on and on and on about
all the people that died from the coid
shots but we don't go on and on and on
about all the men that die from Marriage
every year it is not uncommon and I I
don't say this to to you know um I I
don't say this to be a doom and gloomer
but we have to look at what the reality
of the situation is and inform men of
what it actually is because a
22-year-old that gets married because he
wants to be religious and do the right
thing he has no idea what he's signing
up for besides um I was going to add on
the fifth thing CU I'm also Catholic I
was born and raised Catholic prayer is
not a good indicator of someone's Faith
anyone can pray and this is what this is
what I notice a lot of religious people
don't even realize Faith doesn't dictate
how religious you are what what actually
tells how religious someone is is their
character what they do on a day-to-day
basis outside of prayer because reality
is prayer can literally just be a way
that someone can used to deceive you
King I would say as as literally the
only it seems like I maybe I'm not I
know the soul of everybody here but as a
man of faith I I'm definitely isolated
here and I want to say to you no no I'm
basically in the same thing you're a
father you're a father also
Father s that in other people then you
know no but hold on King I'm also about
15 18 years older than you right so I
say this you know I want to tell you on
the other side of your 40s there are a
lot of men that are happily married and
fathers man yeah I'm not arguing with
that I was talking about the prayer
talking about the prayer thing what I'm
saying is prayer is has nothing to do
with someone's I agree people people
don't have to pray even in even in in
Catholic in our Christian religion it
says it in the Bible that faith without
works is dead so you can have all the
faith all the prayer and the but if you
don't go out into the world and actually
put action to your stuff nothing is
going to happen actions are important no
doubt about it I I just want to
emphasize to people that are watching
it's not all doom and gloom I know a lot
of guys in their 40s that are happily
married but you're in a different
generation and that's the that's the
thing like I'm telling you this and
you're in a different in a different
class that's why you're not putting most
people are not in the situation you most
people would never be around the kind of
people you're around exactly and the
kind of people you around are a minority
not majority and I had this similar I
had a very similar view when I first
came into red pill because I'm from an
upper class area I I've seen that's why
you're like oh have you seen happily
married people hell yeah like yes most
people I grew up around were married but
I realized that I was in a bubble and
that does not that is not the same
situation for workingclass America and I
will never [__] on the average man and
tell him to just become a
multi-millionaire when we need those men
to survive in society so just just
become that's what they'll say just
become 1%
well but even but even then even then
Paul I mean I know plenty of people like
upper class people here and they're
suffering the same issues oh I totally
do like that's the thing that's the
thing too cuz again I'm on the other
like cuz growing up most people were
married that I I didn't do this caveat
now I'm a little bit older and you
actually start to hear about some of
their issues and they start to get
divorced like you're seeing a lot of
like people like growing up 20 year
marriages 30e marriages a lot of them
are getting divorced and you know I
don't I don't say this in a happy way I
didn't choose to make this generation
like I I was just born here but like
I've seen it on the other end so what do
we do uh the only I just just my
personal opinion I really don't see
anything changing until you switch the
laws I think that there should be law
suits filed I think I think we need like
there like you should have billionaires
like Elon Musk who's saying oh family
have kids have kids I'm like well you're
a [__]
billionaire and I'm like you you the
only way average men are going to sign
up is if we change the laws to make them
more fair like it should be at least
50/50 default custody men should be
entitled to see their children yeah cuz
that's one of the things that makes me
uh like petrified as a guy to be in a
like committed relationship is like the
Fallout we've grown up seeing the
Fallout of how men get treated compared
to this whole situation it's like oh my
God if I marry this woman and we get
divorced she takes half of everything I
own she takes the kids I have no I have
no responsibility no control of anything
so to see you and this is what one of
the things I seen that we had in common
one of these things my brother one of
these things hold on one of the things
we have in common is because we've had
access to engage with the type of women
that we wanted to engage with we've been
in the nightclubs we've been in this
environment okay we filled our thirst
media for the engagement of female you
know so we can sit down and say okay
this is not something that I'm actually
l ful for anymore I want something more
simplistic so when I sit down and watch
you and listen to your story about how
you you look at your daughter's eyes and
you you have your wife and stuff like
that me at this level where I already
had my my my plenty of women and stuff
yeah that's what I want that sounds nice
that sounds amazing but for to the
average person that's probably
unrealistic because they haven't even
engaged with about half or even 2% of
the type of women you've engaged with
you know they have the no offense but
and someone and someone in the chat put
the issue is Pearl ignores the fact that
you have the same risk even if you're
not married that's not true um and I
think what they typically do is they'll
they'll conflate Su like men commit
suicide that aren't married as well and
I think the numbers are is similar under
30 is the highest yeah but the the thing
is those men TP if I had to guess that's
the men that are not sexually selected
and just tend to be more I mean men just
have more problems in general but if
you're going to say you're you're not at
RI you're well yeah go ahead it's a very
specific set of risks that you are
taking
sign that legal isn't it that's point I
mean I get the risks but when I see like
my brother and his wife and their two
sons I just know that they're going to
be together forever like yeah that's
discernment yeah how how long have they
been together uh since
May but you could just tell well and and
and you know I just you know God I'm
such AER I'm such a if you become a and
I don't even mean this to be a Doomer
I've just noticed when people tell me
about these couples it tends to be under
15 years and they kind of dwindle out
over 20 25 30 monogamy is supposed to be
50 remember W that I mean you're
supposed to be with someone for a
lifetime so question what what do you
think is the average number to when you
can even think about marriage the
average what like the the the number not
even age like how how long you need to
be in a relationship with a woman or a
guy so you think
about no that's too early you don't even
know each other by that time okay so I I
think that women are a role of the dice
I think I think I think men will are men
are like it's funny they make a rule
they're like they will find a way to
like around it wiggle the average man on
average it takes a man three years to
marry you so you have to date him for
three years so ladies if you're a
certain age it's going to take you
three and this is the thing so so and so
but um I I really even like what Troy
was saying I I have talked to men that
vet girls for 10 years then they got a
kid and went crazy I have talked to men
that dated women for six months that
were amazing wives I just think women
are a role of the dice pick your poison
I think I think it's really difficult to
talk about this issue isn't it because
it's a very emotive issue and clearly
there are men you know and we've heard
what Neeman said I mean there are men
who are incredibly happy with their
wives and their children mean everything
to them and it's it's incredibly moving
to hear those stories and and there's no
doubt that these things exist but I
guess the problem on the other side is
that you have to look at this you have
to look at the figures you have to look
at the stats and you have to hear some
of the anecdotal stuff from the other
side as well and um so I don't I don't
really know the the only answer I think
is that everyone has to look into
themselves and make that decision for
themselves you know what is we need
there need to be a new there needs to be
a new road map for men and one of the
and what I was saying before to I think
like before marriage used to be
something that was you would give
somebody something because they was
giving you something virginity chas E
you know they were but now I think
marriage has to be something as a reward
for a woman now it's before it was like
it was a gift it was like yeah but now
it's a reward so you have the baby first
you live the life first and then reward
you marriage because how can you what
are you actually getting do you
understand what I'm trying to say to you
so I believe in marriage right but we
can't be giving we have to reward you
with marriage now so I'm going to marry
you I would have you if you was a virgin
but you're not a virgin now and so no
but there's some things that we might
need to change now right but I'm still
going to marry you but I'm not going to
give it to you straight away the
Leverage The Leverage a lot of women
will use though is that you know you you
guys are together for two or three years
then and then she's like and then she's
like okay well if you're not going to
put a ring on it you know in the end I'm
going to look somewhere else can't do
that you got but no oh this don't do it
that way around do it that way no but
I'm saying we have to do it like I'm
trying to figure out a new way for men
right I mean honestly China God she's
going to do it again she's going to do
it again go on go on the the truth of
the matter is and I've talked to divorce
attorneys on this and they say I do not
fear marriage marriage is not what I
fear
um you can get married have an ironclad
prup and be virtually okay for the most
part there's exceptions but this is what
they tell me okay but I do fear children
because once you have a child she has
the leverage there's no if ANS or buts
there's nothing you can do that woman
has the leverage because the legal
system will back her you might get lucky
and get a judge that takes your side but
the judges are pretty feminist and they
probably won't so
unfortunately so my plan is not going to
work no my my point my point is when you
have a child like it's really just these
are the risks yeah do I want to take it
and gamble or not and and so and some
men are going to say yes yes it is
absolutely worth it to have a family and
for them I applaud them I say great
amazing go do that but I'm just not in
the business of selling dreams I think
we like people always ask like what are
you in this for reality I just think we
need to like be in what is real and what
is true and the truth of the matter is
that when men have children they are not
their children they are always the
woman's children but there's one topic
that a lot of people are not talking
about is how do you women feel about
that knowing that we have this psycho
anxiety about even committing being in
relationship or even having kids with
you like we have to literally think like
oh my God she can ruin my whole life I'm
so scared they don't care they don't
care they do I think so crazy
they do because lot a lot of girl women
um start a relationship with the hope
that they're going to get married right
and then two three years down the line
that breaks up for whatever reason
usually it could be one or the other or
they go their separate ways but I think
character and discernment are the things
you need to really take into into you
really need to if you're serious about
having a partner a a husband or a wife
you really need to and I do believe
Faith helps with that um I think
discernment and knowing that character
of the person you're with as long as
they're not lying through their teeth
what happened to women that didn't want
to do it alone what happened to women
that wanted to create like like they
wanted to like there used to be
something where women wanted to have the
family then they wanted to meet with
other you know maybe the soccer mom the
gym moms they do things or do the PTA
they come no but but but but you see
this is the point this this is what this
is why this podcast exist men need to
start understanding f female nature the
problem in society today is that men
don't understand female nature what you
just said never exist existed the reason
why that existed back in the day is
because that was the trend that's
why the point is that because that was
the trend then that what Society pushed
so that's what women did now Society is
pushing a different thing and that's
what women are doing so so it depends on
what is pushed in the mainstream and
that's and that's why marriages are SC
like that's why it's so messed up
because you have an entire like think
about the fact that women make less
money and we make 80% of consumer buying
decisions yeah all of the media is
marketing to marketed towards us being
strong and independent towards us
leaving our husbands being single going
out like all of this stuff is marketed
to us most women don't want to be
married they don't want to be wives So
and I've talked to women that literally
homeschooled four children and she told
me she felt so lonely because there just
were not other women that wanted to do
that so basically question say it takes
a village to raise a child so you can
imagine a woman being isolated by
herself so she's not going to want to do
that she going to want to do what her
friends are doing that's what women tend
to do so basically the question is where
are the wives that's that's question
well I I would argue that they three
generations ago so you so you're saying
right now I would say I would say that
if you talked and I there's little
telltale signs that I do to see if a
woman's really a wife and it goes back
to what are your signs do you do you so
I need to know like for all the men this
a good this a good question how does she
react when she's told she's not the [__]
does she argue with you or and and none
of these are guarantees so please don't
come back to me later and so um and the
other the other thing I I usually will
say is I ask like when she asks about
submission obedience like how how does
she feel about that what were what was
her parents relationship like um but I
would say like the biggest things that
you get is does she feel like she needs
a backup
plan Instagram's a backup plan you know
but really it's quite rare we're in 2023
babies so it's like you know um but I
just I just really think that like we've
had two generations of women leading the
women of today astray that have never
heard what men want because the last two
generations of women just didn't give a
[__] yeah you know you but there are
exceptions so don't don't remember there
are exceptions you know you see me
losing hope and you're like no there
there
are I want to I want to but it's it's
tough because if you look at the numbers
the future like that this this is what
they're predicting but now you're seeing
hold hold on right now right now that
you're seeing there are men who are
interested in having wives like there
are there's always there's a shortage of
wives that's the that's the issue
there's a short I don't think it's
there's a problem with men that want to
be married like I think I meet a lot of
men that do want to be married but
here's the thing you sacrifice so or you
risk so much right and then like that
who wants to marry you it's literally no
because at me no not not to you I was
just but you say to me the demographical
girl but you would just listen to loud
noise there was some women in there that
are educated you know they own their own
stuff right but it's just the same thing
as a man you don't want to be battling
your women it shouldn't be that hard and
when you're trying to just speak to them
and then you're having to do that then
you just understand the battle that you
have to go so why would I want to walk
to you in in you know what said you I
might see you and I might think to
myself oh my God you you're my future
wife and I go up to you and then it
takes a lot for a man to go up to women
you think it's easy because you women
don't do it right and then you just
destroy me you like you make me feel to
be a creeper weird dude right no but I
know what you mean no but I'm but do you
understand how he feels get get and I've
said and I've said before women don't
care about men's um feelings all their
mental health only on social media and
buzzword and like no yes we care but
they don't because whenever men speak
and we you said like you know he he's
creepy I get it but a man's not thinking
he's creepy he's thinking oh my God
there's a beautiful woman there I want
to go speak to if he comes to you in a
mad way
that's creepy but I think where do we
get to when men can't even approach
women because of they don't want to be
put on Instagram or or something like
that so I just think like sometimes you
women have to understand how hard it is
for us men and you're not making it any
easier it's lack of communication from
women I think if a woman turns around
and says listen I'm not interested have
a good evening do me in a polite way
that's normally what I would do I don't
turn around and be like oh [__] off
that's called Beautiful air beautiful
air is when is when a guy comes up to
you you don't like him you might even
speak to him and then you're so nice to
him that he tries to get your number
like sorry I got a man or sorry or
whatever car but then they you know what
they respect you because of the way you
treat them how you they actually like
you know what I mean and I'm a strong
believer of that by the way there's no
need to disrespect or be little a man or
think or get your ego up just cuz the
guy's trying to speak just be nice thank
you but no thank you you know what I
mean yeah exactly that's what I do I
mean I don't see a reason to be rude
when's the last time you asked the guy
out when's the last time you asked the
guy out it's been a while I've just been
avoiding the whole
question hey so so so how about this
because I feel like the attitude here is
so is so hopeless and it's so it's so so
many it's it's so it's so like quitter
it's like a quitter it's like someone
has given it's like a dead man walking
it's it is better to love and have lost
and never have loved at all and I just
want to say even the working class guy
even to your point or even the guy that
works as a plumber that works as a
firefighter that's a laborer that works
as a you know a cashier or a bartender
every man exercise 5 six days a week
every man can eat a whole food
plant-based diet for example every man
can read one book every month every man
can can be involved in his community and
volunteer I got I got to disagree with
you but hold on if if if if if if every
man that's a laborer Tes takes his time
to do his self-development and he looks
great naked and he's [__] his wife
good and he's educating himself and he's
stacking his money and he's working hard
and he's reading and he's he's a sexy
beast then I think L less women would
not respect their man my woman respects
no my my wife respects me and I think
and I
think I have a question I have a
question do you think do you think Tom
Brady is in good shape absolutely he's a
beast okay do you think he's on his
aame yeah and he and and and he and he
still got divorced yeah but you want to
know something there's but for every one
gu but we don't first of all know what
happened there but I just want to say
Tom Brady is one example right we can't
relate to these famous people though
come on but but I I I I could I could
give you okay I just interviewed a guy
last week okay and you could you could
tell me ask me tell me if he's better to
have loved and lost and better than to
or whatever you said better to have
loved and lost right so guy yeah yeah so
this guy was um a Bollywood actor with a
modeling contract and he was on his way
up um I forgot he was on like some
Netflix special right and he had one kid
with a
woman and basically what happened is he
hasn't seen his kid in two years two
years he has not seen he doesn't know
who's influencing that child to the
point he has heard that the kid will not
call him dad anymore wait so so his
legacy is gone the kid does not
acknowledge Him as his father and
they're now switching his last name
hasn't seen the kid in two years on top
of that this woman got him fired because
they said that he raped that he raped
her like 10 years ago even though they
were married or whatever I like she and
she was so into him she could she
changed religions for this man so it
wasn't like she didn't respect him in
the beginning okay but you wa wait wait
wait wait so now he and he told me he
said you know sometimes I just think
about committing suicide just because
it's like what what do I have now his
kid's gone every he he can't work
because he everyone thinks he's an
abuser rapist and on top of that um I
mean his wife's gone too like so I I
just don't know how in good faith like
if we're being truly honest with
ourselves you can say it's better to
have loved and lost for that guy in that
situation and that is not uncommon okay
so I want to really address this I also
I also want to add one more thing he was
in his uh 40s I think okay so it's not
like he's a you know if that happens to
you at 28 you can rebuild you can figure
it out okay put so put a like so let's
just take a bigger context here let's
look at in general can I give a
guarantee that this will not happen to
you no but I can say you can have higher
probability when in in the United States
about 67% of the people have obesity
about one more than onethird of the
people are overweight if out of 10 of
those men that are labor class they go
to the gym five days a week they eat
clean at home organic they're reading
one book a month they're investing in
their community and making volunteer
volunteering and being reading a good
book whether it's the Bible Quran or the
Torah and they're making a real effort
for self-improvement on a continual
basis and they're working on their
mental attitude on a daily basis I do
think out of hold on hold on I do think
out of 10 of those men you're right
maybe three of them would still cheat on
them and leave them but I I think seven
of them maybe so I've got I've there's
two there's two differences I hear the
Obesity thing a lot like okay there's
70% but you can make different choices
the difference is I I think that's a
fundamental misunderstanding of female
nature women feel one thing one day they
feel another thing the other but is it
important for wait wait wait so I'm not
I'm not saying it's not important but
what I'm saying is what you eat is in
your control when you're married it is
not in your control yeah there is there
is no way you can I I have talked to
okay I just I just spoke to a guy that
was a two-time MLB Champion baseball so
you're telling me a two-time MLB
Champion just should have did more I'm
talking about you can improve your ODS
you can improve your odds but at what
percent of men does this have to happen
to to for it to be negligent you will
have a much higher rate you will have a
much higher rate of success if as a man
you take responsibility for looking good
to your for your wife naked you will you
have a responsibility for [__] you
have the responsibility
for I agree with
you I look good naked I'm keep it real
so so that's a part
of so and I'm not saying that that
doesn't that that's not a part of it but
again it always goes to women feel one
way and they feel another Inc consisten
I I have talked to men that I mean we
can do famous examples of men that
literally had everything and yet their
wife still left yeah because we're not
even taking into consideration the best
the um what's it called the pills that
these women take for better control yeah
exactly effects so even if your woman
might be attracted to you at the
beginning and then she goes the pill
which most women have been on the pill
yes you might look good and she might
just still not be attracted to you after
like 5 years yeah if if you if you took
a pill right and if if they issued a
pill and 2% of people died that would be
considered negligent they would be wait
wait they would be sued and I know this
isn't like a fun reality I don't say
this in a happy way but again I'm just
I'm not in the business of selling
dreams neither am I and I just and I
just think that a lot of s when you say
oh just out just do this do this do this
it sounds nice but the truth of the
matter is the media is telling women to
do the wrong thing her friends are
telling her to do the wrong thing social
media is telling her to do the wrong
thing and on top of that she is paid she
is given money and nobody if we took the
emotion out of it right if that was a
business deal everyone would say oh my
God I would never take that deal but
because we're really attached to it we
don't like the way these numbers make us
feel right which I understand um you
know um I think a lot of times we have a
hard time having like a real
conversation about it but the truth is
the majority of men will not win Pearl
if you have a hundred men that are
physically fit capable they're
continuously educating themselves
they're eating clean they look good
naked they're [__] their wife good I
think out of a hundred in that in that
in that control group if in that control
group compared to a randomized group I
think in that control group you have way
more whose wife are happy with him I I
think that women are women and if that
were true then the men in Hollywood
would just have amazing long successful
marriage I'm talking about percentages
I'm talking about percentages I think
okay well then we could take athletes
and entertainers they're all very
goodlook a lot of are Che on their
they're all but you you said you your
your standard was looks and right now
I'm trying to explore that idea now
you're changing it right so so wait wait
wait wait so and I'm saying okay let's
explore looks well when you look at
Hollywood when you look at athletes they
their marriages don't really last long I
also think I also think women can I also
think women can get the ick as as they
call it these days for for for for other
reasons other than looks you know like
I've I've known many dudes you know
decent looking dudes they're with a girl
for you know three four years or
whatever and then she just goes off him
for some stupid [__] thing that he
did and it's not because he's not in
shape I I I would agree with you in
terms of self-improvement I think
everybody should be regardless everybody
should be self-improving the whole damn
time I think we should be going to the
gym I think we should be reading you
know uh Naval ra ravad talks about
reading for an hour a day very few
people do it we should be doing that we
should be you know enriching ourselves
in many different ways but whether
that's really I I would agree with you
probably over a 100 people it's going to
improve the odds of a proportion of
those people but is it really going to
change the dog because she might just
get she might just you know I mean it
seems like women's emotions can turn on
a dime and even even more than that even
more than that actually the reality is
like that premise of of everyone should
improve is not a good argument because
if let's assume okay everyone was to
improve and everyone was to go to gym
everyone was to start making money women
are still only going to go for the top
10 at the end of the day so even if
everyone improves women will just raise
their standards higher that's what's
going to happen the impetus is always on
the guys isn't it the impetus is always
well the guys are got to shape up then
you know you've got to do better in
order
to always want the best out of the bunch
so even if every guy was to start going
to the gym because every guy is not
going to to the gym and all we're all
going to look the same some men are
still short some men are still tall so
women will still always select for the
best out of the bunch and the thing is
every metric people give me they'll be
like okay just find a churchgoer like
and then I'll say okay these are the
numbers for churchgoers and the numbers
are still bad now I'm sorry one out of
four uh divorce which I it's arguably
higher than that but I'm going to go
with the number they give me
25% that's still bad that is still risky
you you we're talking about a game of
probabilities here would you agree on
that this is a game of prob I would say
I would say this is a game of risks
versus rewards agre yeah so so I would
say that every single man can take full
ownership and responsibility over
looking good naked [__] his wife good
going to the gym five six days a week
reading one book a month working really
hard saving his money living below his
means that is those are variables that
every
and and being not being a drunk and even
if you do that you will still have a
good chance of getting divorced but you
have a high you have a much higher still
you you it will be less likely but you
will still have a good but you have a
higher probability of success regardless
you will it will be more likely that you
will succeed but you still have a
significant chance of divorce which is
which is a for a lot of men suicide hold
on hold on I I got a question I really
got a question no and I and I don't and
I know you laugh but like I'm telling
you I I've I've spoken if you if you've
T if you if you've seen like what men
look like when they can't access their
children it's not really funny like it's
reallyy I know I know a guy who hasn't
seen his daughter for for years and I
just want to emphasize but but I want to
know a question I want I got a question
I want to know based off everything that
you two females have heard right I'm
excluding Pearl because she's a
conversationalist you I give you average
type of
women
you're to thaton in a second I'm talking
that was that was a test that was a test
for average yeah I'm talking about like
as of like normal people you know based
off all the things that men have to go
through and everything that they just
said that this Comforts The the way that
we basically got our hands tied how do
you feel about hearing this happening to
men so I think it I think like that is a
risk and I think that love should
conquer it but but
I no I do care I do care I do think that
you know ideally like if I get married I
do not want to get divorced I do not
want to be that stat that PE keeps
saying I don't want to be in the broken
down family with like a kid that doesn't
see his father that's horrific I'd
rather be single personally than go
through then
not no then not have the discernment or
the the you have to have a bit of trust
you have to go
some way if you are it depends who
you're mixing with though right if you
go out and you're meeting people and and
you're just meeting people in the wrong
environment I don't think you understand
the question I know but I'm just expl do
I care what men think about it yes I do
care no do you care do you care about
the effects that it's having on men yes
I care because it's effect it is
directly affecting everyone in society
so of course I care it it's that's not
what we want however I do think that men
have a responsibility to be a bit more
concerning and not go straight for the
the big ass or whatever it is and not
actually think about what if we like the
big
ass you can like the big ass but realize
that there's more just go for a smaller
one if you want to get married but even
even if you call I call them lowrisk and
highrisk women like like you know chess
tattoo high
risk older older highrisk younger lower
risk so but the thing is like there's no
guarantees my favorite test my favorite
test for a wife is to tell her to open
her mouth real wide just so I could see
if I could fit it
in I think your German wife did when you
first met them wow wow I think I think
the crazy thing about this is the
shocking part about this is if this was
the roles were reverse and this was men
people would be like oh my God how are
you going through this stressful anxiety
filled situation throughout your life
now men do go through a lot to be honest
with you a pressure a lot of but we're
all going through you adva are you
advocating for
I've always I don't know I don't know
I'm just
list I understand I understand that you
say that we all go through it we all
going through things yeah we are all
going through things but we're talking
about something that directly impacts by
women to men we're talking about
something that women and men have full
control over and you're sitting here
watching multiple different men from
multiple different cultures from all
across the world sit down and tell you
we're going through a lot right now and
we're still trying to be men but we
don't know our hands are tied we have a
lot of pressure anxiety can I want I
want to point out something when men
talk about their problems women always
have a have like this tendency to find a
way to blame
them see you see you see like her first
reaction was well you're going for the
big ass like what' you
expect it's okay it's okay like it's not
just you it's like every chick but I've
just done so many of
these and it's funny men kind of have
the same tendency too where they're like
well you should have worked
out and so it's like I don't know men
just really don't get empathy like I
don't feel like y feel bad or even feel
like yo that's crazy it's I think it's
communication between men and women are
just is all about communication I think
communication makes I think
communication makes it worse I think
communication no with a logical mind a
woman has a logical mind no no we none
of us do I don't even none of us like
come to emotions all too emotional look
at the natural response that she gave I
asked the particular question and she
said but we're all going through St and
it's like yo I think Society has like
messed us all up we're all mess up I'm
not married I don't have kid you want to
be married wait wait wait wait wait I
have a I have a question I have I have a
I going to ring I have a question I have
a question who who creates society and
the culture well at the moment we have a
whole heap of people but it's
predominantly men at the moment the
women so no so who's who's the media
marketed towards women depends don't be
in dep wa wait wait
so
okay okay okay okay listen listen listen
if women make 80% of consumer buying
decisions who is the media marketed
towards with that notion it would be
women okay who is music marketed towards
both no come on try again what try again
look at look at the songs on the radio
who are the songs marketed to it's both
it depends it's not it's not so if women
are making 80% of consumer buying
decisions think about this again who is
who is it marketed towards it depends in
the charts right now please please
please be honest I am being honest it
depends on the artist I'm telling you
it's mostly women okay okay okay so next
next we're going to go to
institutions colleges who are they
marketed towards generally don't know
both students try again try again try
again I don't I think so so now women
are almost 70% of college applicants
true okay so America both America and
the West okay okay now who are who are
the universities marketed towards
generally don't know because when I when
I was at try try try I have more guys
okay so if 70% of applicants if there's
more female applicants now than before
women spend 80% okay who is it marketed
torts I guess females but I'm not aware
of
that this is just this is just a like
this is just a thought exercise okay you
said women three times okay okay so so
now I have a question I have a question
if the woman is you typically spends
more time you forgot one more question
one more question who are who is raising
the
kids so like I don't know who was
allowed to raise the kids we just
majority who are the majority of people
raising the kids yeah who knows no no
okay okay so let me let me get this
straight we just did a whole show we
just did a whole show this is this is
okay thank
you you thank you thank you so who is
responsible for the
culture I still think it I no because
wait when you're okay I know what you're
saying about raising whatever the women
are whatever however when you're making
laws and stuff it's predominantly men wa
wait please stop please stop I'm making
a point guys so wait wait so now you're
going to say the laws right okay okay
who is who is the majority of the
population it's about 50/50 isn't it Noe
nope it's a slightly more what gender
okay who is who is the biggest swing
voter group maybe women so who are laws
created for
women so so who are responsible for
these laws fine fine women
I all right now I do think simps are an
equally big of a problem I do think I do
really hate simps so I'm not I'm not
trying to the simps let all this happen
right they should have been like oh no
these women are getting out of hand guys
take this away right like women's sports
I think men should stop S I love I love
volleyball personally but I'm just so
sick of seeing these [__] wine I'm
like take this away I would just cut it
but they keep complaining about the pay
because they don't make any money but
different different day but you know so
it's like who's responsible for the
culture now I don't say this you know to
hate on women but it just seems like
whenever we get power it just
goes about what about Margaret Thatcher
oh my God no oh no let's not get
politics I
don't so so okay so I'll we'll go we'll
actually we'll actually go I I don't
know much about Margaret Thatcher and
herself but I will give you a little bit
of history on Queens and women in power
uh let me give you a hint do you think
it's good or
bad oh God the answer is not women no I
will I will acknowledge there have been
some Queens in history that have done
great things there are exceptions to
every rule some women were raised to do
that they're usually you know raised by
a high status guy that's typically
however women are more likely to wage
war women are more likely to spend and
that's
why women shouldn't
vote great I see how you did that did
thank you everybody where can somebody
buy that so guys get this at the
audacity
network.
Shopify um the link to that is in the
description thanks everyone for coming
let's do a round of
applause um okay why don't everyone do
final thoughts tonight so here go around
and then we'll do second row we lost her
where' the chick in the middle go she
had enough oh yeah well and I thought we
were being I thought she was my friend
but some some people have trains or
whatever so go go ahead go ahead okay
final thought everyone love everyone
have some respect for each other if we
all live with respect with love and
peace we shall Thrive as a community
that's it peace love that is not true at
all I just needed to go ahead um I I
would say um I respect what everyone
said here I hope a lot of you have a
good uh attitude and have some hope and
be a little bit more romantic and also
uh if you want to learn how to not be a
[__] uh this is my book published by
D&G and on November 17th I'll be at the
City Winery in New York City doing a
HomeTown show on November
17th
um I think I agree with Laura as well I
think um just having think a lot more
understanding between one another and
growth and we did mention earlier on
about the the average person and I'm
launching a a podcast actually tomorrow
with uh talking to every single uh
London worker that's an average
individual just listening to normal
stories so bringing back the voice the
everyday person I think we forget the
average individual so who's your first
show with a bus driver a woman bus
driver oh very
cool
it's the podcast called London's working
so it will be launched on YouTube
tomorrow so
yeah thank
you Troy uh yeah I'm Troy um thank you
for having me on PA as always it's been
a great show um I think that having a
sort of lifestyle of promiscuity and
being a Playboy and just having this
continuous one night stands and stuff I
don't think that's a recipe for for
happiness I think it can you know as
people have said it does become pretty
empty it becomes pretty syy and all the
rest of it having said that I think long
long-term monogamy is problematic as
well and I think that obviously you know
we've heard a lot about the risks
involved with marriage and so on and so
forth so I think it's just it's got to
be down to the individual right and
there's there's an element of I don't
want to say choose your own poison
because that's a very unromantic way of
putting it but I think you've got to
make the decision for yourself okay
where do I want to which way do I want
to go and then you've just got to go
with that and run with it you know and
except there might be some risks but
that's just life there's going to be
risks whatever you do and I don't think
that one is a definite route to
happiness and the others a definite
route to unhappiness I think that you
know people have different outcomes
depending on their individuality um we
have got a dating boot coming up in
Mexico City on the 5th to the 8th of
October so if you're interested in that
you can drop me an email troytroy
francis.com and just follow me on
YouTube which is at real Troy Frances
thank
you wow
um first thing I'll say is for the guys
who don't are do not have as much
accessibility to the type of women that
you want my best advice for you guys the
the more uccess you get the more types
of women you'll be able to engage with
so work on yourself same thing that
these guys were saying earlier work on
yourself put a lot more effort into
becoming more successful in your
particular field and you'll have a lot
more opportunities to get into more
engagements with women but at the same
time you'll reach to a level where you
don't really want to engage with
multiple different women you rather have
that one single family oriented and
you'll move forward Pearl just to
clarify it's my first time AC being on
this show and I had so many perspectives
on what type of person you'll be
especially being American especially
being black and to be
honest for real I'mma keep it real you
know I'mma keep it real I I I was
wondering how this would go the whole
time you know and surprisingly this
whole conversation has been very
informative yeah this a little Jazz but
this is a show this is how we got to
make it interent but I don't feel like
you know throughout this particular
broadcast I don't feel like this that
you've stepped over the line the only
thing that was stepped over the line a
little bit was calling people black
people and gay but we address that we
address that what am I suppos what am I
supposed to call them purple
I I I but China another thing bro you're
a solid dude I really rock with you bro
and I'm happy that you was even here
today real talk no I respect that thank
you bro from a black from America to a
black in in UK bro no I love for that I
I respect it my name is Adonis crash
boom you can find me on YouTube
Instagram Tik Tok uh I'm out here
interviewing these London people and
then just debing the situation that
Americans are not all dumb and it's just
entertainment formative content don't
take it too seriously learn and share
her live stream share this video share
the content yes um had fun today thanks
P for having me again um follow me on
social media Al be the
artist yeah um my name is Tron the man's
voice thank you to pear thank you to all
the panelists um today it's always a
pleasure to be on the show shout out to
King the produc star shout out to all
new centuries U New Century consultants
and yeah man make sure you subscribe to
my Channel today I hit 2000 up today so
that
go um so yeah and and yeah like a lot of
content's been going viral so yeah just
thank you to everyone that keeps tuning
into to me and thank you to everyone
that you know that comes on platforms
with me and gives me the opportunity to
to to grow a little bit you know so yeah
you want me to answer do you want me to
answer do you want me to
answer yeah but yeah and and yeah just
shout out to all the blogs and and
everybody that's posting and sharing the
content because like we can't do it
alone and like he said like sometimes it
can look a bit Wild here but it's a bit
of WWE it's a bit of entertainment but
at the end of the day it's always a good
show and there's always all love at the
end of it yeah definitely all right guys
um make sure you get your women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today I don't
know what more I have to do to convince
you this was a idea now look at we love
the shout out to the mothers out there
that are amazing the awesome wives you
know I don't want to be too down but
they you guys barely exist anymore
sorry
but I do appreciate you know um the ones
and I do know some amazing mothers and
wives so um guys make sure you like the
video and sign up for our email list um
to be notified when we do our next event
a couple of you came to it you know was
fun um and I think we're going to do an
actual live show soon with an audience
we're going to sell tickets so I think
it'll be fun like the video I'll talk to
you next
[Music]
[Applause]
time